e
[Musique]
ah ah ouais t'as vu ce qui se passe à
tous au nom de quoi tu parles tu rigoles
ou quoi la radio ou à la télé les
journaux tout le monde enfin à l'autre
mais oui ce matin chez lui au pressing
m'attends à tout moment pas à l'autre
c'est foutu c'est que je ferai quand il
alors d'aventuré on parlait aussi mieux
si l'on parle lui aussi lourd passif il
en pense d'ailleurs que tout le monde
encore voici le nouvel épisode du mont
amba
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec thierry ardisson
en afrique
philippe portier
il y a
izia
méline
beaulieu
les deux thèmes
non
plus les guest star du soir charlotte
gainsbourg
elisabeth teissier
orlando le frère de dalida tito
et demi
noël ma main
[Applaudissements]
latifa à
et jean moulin
amélie château luisier west bay
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez l'équipe voici l'aube un
fou
si vraiment de vous arrêter certains les
bassistes alors donc après l'hymne de
bassiste laurent
nous avons reçu une nouvelle chanson
consacrée à l'émission consacrée à la
question clotilde courau que tout le
monde connaît ici combien de fois
embrasse auriez-vous jeu les chaussettes
sales de votre jules par amour et voici
la chanson till même les choses les
chaussettes fethi 608
ces cités elle embrasse un film sur les
chaussettes chaussettes fétide
alors c'est pas mal mais ça ressemble un
peu à bout c'est pompé sur un truc à un
état dit pas quelque chose ça me
rappelle un truc mais pour envoyer vos
chansons et on les mettra sur un cd une
fois pour toutes qui sera édité après
noël
alors laurent sexe magouille et culture
générale au gymnase n'a qu'une chose à
faire marche toujours très volontiers ça
commence à baisser un petit peu non non
ça marche très très bien on est toujours
aussi heureux de jouer ça et on commence
à se roder parce qu'on a joué ça va plus
de 150 fois maintenant donc ça va
vraiment plus en plus drôle ouais c'est
plus en plus drôle laurent oui il ya des
bassistes ici je sais pas j'espère
je le dis parce que la semaine dernière
il disait pareil je me suis fait à
tâcher d'un seul coup dès maintenant je
regarde le public maintenant mais on a
trouvé un moyen d'éradiquer les
bassistes
françois collet attend bahreïn jingle
[Musique]
non
ou celui qui a une tradition dans cette
émission c'est de diffuser chaque
semaine les meilleurs moments de
l'émission précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par monsieur jean hugues
noël magnéto serge à lui seul du soir
récent de tour de poitrine c'est vrai ça
n'arrivait d'un coup en plus jusqu'à 17
ans j'étais comme la table mais non au
long sur la plage voilà fatwa toi je
vais t'attraper j'ai dit ça peut
commander
j'avais une petite amourette avec
prim'toit ouais ça commençait vachement
tôt il le vendredi soir quand j'ai
quitté l'école je prenais l'avion je
faisais paris boston boston minneapolis
et janvier le dimanche inutile de dire
que les devoirs et les courges et
n'importe quoi c'est pas ça ça a duré
longtemps sa fille avait eu une aventure
avec galabru t'aurais pas redoublés non
plus mais qui sont en sursis s'est pas
revu sa fille tu vas la parole d'accord
cela dit on peut encore s'exprimer
je voyais à céline dion et alors tu as
d'autres questions non mais si joker
c'est gilles qui répond si je dis non à
ma première télé je crois quand céline
j'ai l'air con comme tu dis oui aussi
christophe de méricourt qui dit ma femme
et moi on fait souvent l'amour devant
ton émission
pourrais tu lui dire que la fellation
est une chose naturelle dans le couple
j'aurais peut être une chance grâce à
toi non c'est pas un truc naturel la
rédaction
très nature et vous avez déclaré dans
france football
je refuse toutes les émissions de
télévision sauf celle de thierry
ardisson
vous êtes la meilleure
[Applaudissements]
quel péché qui vous tente le plus gênant
c'est la liste parce que la bri c'est le
peuple c'est le seul péché qu'on peut
avoir même quand on est pauvre
vous feriez quoi s'il vous restait 24
heures à vivre je me ferai un petit
plateau télé
ouais je voyais un petit whisky voilà
c'est terrible c'est terrible alors que
vous aimez pas prier dans une église
dans un centre-ville
je vais vous dire très franchement à 24
heures ça sert plus à rien votre nom de
famille c'est adams fait particules et
il est coauteur avec keren ann wind à
mes débuts à la télévision mais vous
aviez une autre coiffure mais vous aviez
les chocs de court ce qui vous rend
rouge de honte d'être mal coiffée
quand l'avez réflexion c est ce qui vous
énerve le plus chez moi
non pourquoi non je serais pas venu
chance et annonce même un peu oui non
mais j'ai même une certaine passion
parce qu'il est vrai que parce que
j'aime bien que je sois toujours en noir
cette plaie ça que chance il a démenti
c'était du mal
dans la dalle
[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs
alors vous le savez à la fin des
missions toutes les semaines il ya un
blind test et ce soir le blind test est
consacrée à ceux qui chantent en famille
les frères les soeurs les pères les
filles qui ont chanté ensemble pour
arbitrer ce blind test j'appelle un
homme au dessus de tout soupçon massue
avait les porter
g
je reçois pays
bah ça va mon chéri matt la place du
mechouar
faites des gosses
allez faites des gosses il faut les
assumer a fait un saut qui dit aulas une
partie avec ses deux juges de touche
tallien et issia bonsoir les filles
venues parce que vous avez de quoi les
jets de quoi calmer talla alias il
triche au blind test est très bien s'il
ne triche pas si j'avais plus jamais
justement bien philippe houzé de près on
va passer aux jeux idiots veille au soir
c'est le bras de fer
didier music man & co attention
attention
[Musique]
le croiser à les pensions
[Applaudissements]
oh
c'est à dire gagner droits régaliens
merci mairie et là tout est là
allez
merci en l'air tout à l'heure
le 27 mai
ils sont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant monsieur charlotte
[Musique]
et
prochain
[Musique]
voici charlotte gainsbourg
bienvenue charlotte pour votre première
à tout le monde en parle
alors que miller a dit en parlant de
vous charlotte est une actrice née comme
mozart était un musicien né un peu trop
pour vérifier en tout cas à nouveau dans
le film ma femme est une actrice réalisé
par votre compagnon j'aime bien ce mot
compagnon si joli si j'ai peu désuet un
peu obsédé compagnon yvan attal avec tes
reinstein noémie love clic est
magnifique dans le film qui est très
très drôle de mon magnifique aussi le
rubato et lionel abelanski que de très
bons acteurs
alors vous dites en tournant ce film
j'avais l'impression de le faire du
cinéma pour la première fois de ma vie
et c'est assez paradoxal puisque vous
joué pratiquement votre propre rôle dans
le film celui d'une actrice prénommée
charlotte et yvan attal vie avec vous
bien entendu dans la vraie vie comme
dans le film
la seule différence c'est qu'il est
journaliste sportif alors pourquoi cette
impression de faire du cinéma pour la
première fois parce que je les ai vécus
comme comme un premier film
ouais parce que je l'aï accompagné
pendant pendant toute l'écriture et sans
participer mais je les ai vus à toutes
les étapes et j'avais le trac comme si
c'était mon premier film alors le pitch
sa part d'un court métrage qui avait
fait ils vont attal qui s'appelait got a
woman et finalement qu'il a transformé
avec l'aide de claude berri le
producteur en un long métrage alors
c'est l'histoire d'un mec jaloux qui
supportent pas de vivre avec une actrice
parce qu'elle embrasse pour defour bien
sûr mais bon des mecs toute la journée
et que parfois pour de faux bien sûr
mais bon il couche avec eux donc
effectivement il n'apprécie pas du tout
il supporte pas ça le rend carrément
cinglé cette histoire non ça le rend
très jaloux très jeune mais il est d'un
tempérament jaloux enfin le personnage
est d'un tempérament jal
elle n'est pas une comédie sur la
jalousie très enlevé très bien éclairé
bien réalisé bien monter c'est un
bonheur ça va marcher moi je vous dis un
truc
les américains vont racheter l'histoire
pour faire le remake alors ça peut pas
être tom cruise et nicole kidman parce
qu'ils sont plus ensemble mais pourquoi
pas on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
mal et auxerre mais franchement c'est
très fâché de 21 ans bras c'est un mec
dans un film même couché avec lui
surtout qu'en plus il retrouvait ses
plusieurs fois enfin il me l'a fait au
nom je te jure ça m'a parlé ça te fait
raconter comment tu as toute la journée
un jeu me trémousser tu es malade ou
quoi
vas-y toi pour ton petit présentement ce
que vraiment un cours de théâtre mousser
pour voir pour comprendre le trip
vous allez nous faire la naissance d'une
fleur non fortune flore enfin pour un
croc j'en ai vu des films quand ils
s'embrassent s'embrassent
alors
tél
j'étais couché avec peter n'y a que ça
qui est intéressant il ya la britannique
aussi mais là en l'occurrence oui et
c'est ça qui m'intéresse car juste le
fait que tout le monde puisse avoir à
quoi maintenant je pêche
sur ce match sauf que le catch est un
bon pote déjà hier soir madrasa j'avais
la trique t'imagines acteurs la gaule
qui devait avoir
[Musique]
ça va s'arranger et moi ça va changer
j'en ai toujours eu pour ton fils alors
depuis qu'il a d'expatriés alors là
c'est de mal en seconde ça mais aussi du
show bar qu'elle fait mon avis je vais
encore plus d'un autre supporter tous y
retient je pourrais pas demander un
traitement avec des charges
c'est l'histoire un peu vrai d'ailleurs
parce qu inspiré d'une aventure vécue
puisque quand vous faisiez loeb et
cetera avec marion vernoux il était
copain avec charles berling et jour
l'histoire dans le scénario l'histoire
c'est un peu approfondis entre berling
et vous n'avez plus envie de boire des
verres avec lui après le tirage
c'est sûr qu'on fait tout pour croire à
ce qu'on jours donc on peut se laisser
aller aux sentiments les personnages
mais c'est vrai qu'au delà des rapports
au tactile c'est à dire se toucher se
serrer dans les bras
s'embrasser dans le même lit il ya quand
même des rapports de séduction des
rapports amoureux quand on joue avec
quelqu'un oui moi je pense que c'est à
elle le plus dangereux c'est pas
forcément les restes obligatoirement son
père disait que dans les plateaux il y
avait un climat aphrodisiaques c'est
pour ça qu'ils surveillaient ta mère sur
la piscine mais c'est vrai que c'est
propice à en est fragilisée sur un sur
un plateau de tournage et donc c'est
vrai on est plus sensible et c'est vrai
qu'on se sent un peu dans les sentiments
qu'on doit éprouver derrière une scène
qui est très bien dans le film en
question dans ma femme est une actrice
c'est quand vous êtes en train de jouer
aux échecs dans la caravane de tournage
avec terrine stade et que yvan attal
arrive effectivement bien ce qui se
passe de prendre un de coucher avec lui
mais vous êtes dans son intimité quand
même vous attend dans une intimité avec
terrine stains on comprend bien et
pourtant il n'y a pas de geste est rien
oui c'est vrai je suis gêné parce que je
fais surprises dont ya un laisser-aller
il laissait aller qui peut arriver il
n'ya pas toujours des histoires d'amour
sur tous les plateaux de tournage mais
puis on vit c'est une vie intense
pendant quelques mois ci une aventure
alors d'ailleurs yvan attal vous l'avez
rencontrée en 1990 sur le tournage d'
aux yeux du monde
le film d'eric rochant donc c'est arrivé
une fois ça peut encore arriver en même
temps pour le moment ça va avec yvan
tout va bien revenir très amoureux l'un
de l'autre quand on vous voit ensemble
et votre enfant ben va bien est ce qu'il
est circoncis sept enfants c'est un des
grands sujets c'est un des grands sujets
noémie lvovsky est très drôle parce
qu'elle est mariée avec un goal un non
juif et elle veut absolument faire
circoncire son fils et lui veut pas et
c'est très bien c'est très bien raconté
c'est très rigolo
ouais ouais c'était un sujet qui les
touche m fm vous avez fait quoi vous
laissiez circoncire votre fils mais moi
non
maintenant vous êtes toujours été très
attiré par la religion juive bien que
n'étant pas juive puisque votre mère ne
l'est pas mais c'était toujours très
très attirés oui j main
j'ai eu une attirance l'âge où ça arrive
genre à l'adolescente
serge gainsbourg lui croyant rien il
fait terriens je ne sais pas on lui fait
jubiler fait tout ce qui est tradition
mais moi j'ai pas oui de la sacem quand
même ça me rend de fait vous avez pas
souffert de ma mère est une actrice où
mon père est un chanteur n'avait pas
souffert de ça je crois pas je crois que
je me suis même pas posé la question
c'était comme ça non je crois pas
souffert le seulement vous avez un petit
peu souffert c'est quand ils sont
séparés c'est tout ouais comme pour tous
enfin pour tous les enfants
non mais c'est pas parce que vous avez
un peu les mêmes souvenirs que romane
bohringer c'est à dire que l son père
l'emmenait comme ça dans les dents les
boîtes de nuit à l'âge de quatre pattes
deux ans mais enfin des gens l'âge de
5-6 ans et vous parlait il ya deux ans
vous étiez dans des boîtes vous endormir
sur les banques est bien passé pour
garder un bon souvenir très bon j'en
avais une vie à la fois très stable et
et un peu folle parce qu'on est suivi
ouais et alors je vous êtes sur un
plateau c'est le plateau de la pirate
qui est réalisé par votre beau père
jacques doillon et jane birkin big à ce
moment là vous avez porté sur l'actrice
laure marsac un regard de jalousie
est-ce que c'était une envie d'être
actrice
ou est-ce que c'était au contraire
simplement parce que vouliez qu'on fasse
attention à vous je crois pas je crois
que je crois que c'était pas un réel
désir de d'être actrice ou de jouer quoi
que ce soit étant enfant ne voyez pas
spécialement le désir de faire comme
votre mère non je crois pas vous avez
commencé d'une façon très très marrante
un jour jane birkin se s'en va et laisse
un petit mot sur la table elie chouraqui
cherche une ado de ton âge vas-y
pourvoir vous y allez vous êtes choisis
c'est génial
ces paroles et musiques ouais j'ai
jamais pris de cours non j'aurais aimé
je suis sûr que j'aurais pris du plaisir
à le faire mais j'ai pas osé et après
paroles et musique vous avez voulu
partir en suisse dans une pension alors
que finalement votre mère et kate vous
disais c'est détestable il va pas assez
insupportable et pensions vous êtes
parti un an dans une pension en suisse
et vous avez assez bien vécu moi j'ai
très bien vécu
je pense que j'avais envie d'un truc
rigoureux et vous aviez besoin
d'autorité y avait passé la maison
s'il y en avait mais j'avais envie de
toi tu avais envie de passer par les
mêmes choses qu'eux
r que ma soeur et et de contraindre
moi-même ah ouais j'ai besoin de
discipline alors serge gainsbourg disait
en parlant de vous charlotte est une
orchidée déguisé en orties de moins en
moins de moins en moins orties de plus
en plus orchidées c'est vrai qu'avant
vous étiez d'une timidité maladive là
vous avez l'air beaucoup mieux quand
même ça s'est arrangé
non seulement vous réfugier un peu dans
le silence avant vous étiez un peu
angoissé non pas angoissé j'étais très
très timide
je ne sais pas d'efforts pour volonté
contre on va voir à l'époque comment
c'était
magnéto serge la gagnante et charlotte
gainsbourg
e
merci
merci qui
je remercie club de m'avoir fait pour le
voir laisser faire ce film
claude miller la remercie claude milet
cinq jours et césar en 86 très calme on
soutient un peu comme ça la tête dans
les épaules et tous là vous êtes un peu
plus j'étais jeune très jeune de
déclassement c'est ça à l'époque vous
disiez souvent je suis pas une vraie
actrice comme ça si si ça marchait pas
vous auriez pu dire c'est pas et c'était
pas mon truc c'est ça hein
maintenant ça y est vous avez vend ses
pensées jamais avec ce métier ça peut
s'arrêter
ouais à chaque film vous êtes toujours
envie de tout arrêter ou non non c'est à
chaque team où j'ai l'impression de tout
recommencer
bah vous ici de vous arrêter puis comme
vous savez pas quoi faire d'autre vous
recommencez alors ils vont vous a
décoincé quand même temps pour la prépa
de ce film je parle et vous à vous a
fait dire le texte à haute voix il vous
a oui on a eu des séances de travail
très très intenses drôle maintenant
quand je repense mi mai
difficile difficile il me poussait il
essayait de il voulait que je me sens
clip sur le tournage donc il voulait
glace j'avais trop loin peut-être en
préparant et de jose mais c'était même
dur devant lui devais faire des choses
surtout que c'était dans un petit bureau
chez pathé la première dont complet
s'était pas non plus chez vous à la
maison
il voulait que vous soyez un personnage
heureux bien dans sa peau c'est vrai que
dans le film d'ailleurs vous est
vachement légère quoi oui oui il voulait
que je sois que je sois ouverte que je
sois gay ça ça vous a aidé est ce que
votre psychanalyste vous a aidé aussi
avoue décoincer sûrement ouais c'est
fini maintenant je sais pas j'ai jamais
fait moi j'aimerais savoir comment ça se
passe non si jamais fini je pense qu
enfin c'est fini mais faire tomber leur
accent sur vous a fait progresser sa
masse hama
ça m'a permis d'enfin je sais comment
faire
j'ai des solutions vous savez où il faut
aller chercher la solution maintenant
oui ça veut pas dire que j'y vais mais
je sais comment jamais un rapport avec
votre image ou simplement vous y pense
et plus je m'en fous parfois je sais pas
si je m'en fous je fais un tout petit
peu plus détendu et c'est moins grave
ouais d'accord oui ça va mieux c'est
vrai que est un enfant vous ressenti un
petit peu être vilain petit canard de la
famille vous dit j'étais entouré de deux
de jane de quais de lou doillon de
bambou et vous étiez un peu malheureuse
complexe et aux malheureuses pas
malheureuse complexe et j'étais très
complexée ouais parce que je pense que
dans ma famille la beauté c'était
quelque chose d'important
là il ya des scènes dans le film vous
êtes parfait vous savez la mema
soignants s'est bien occupé tout
[Musique]
charlotte gainsbourg on va voir où vous
en êtes sur le plan psychologique
on va faire une interview qui va mesurer
vos peurs et vos angoisses ans ne bouge
pas pendant les géniales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean le gainsbourg donc interview peur
bleue est ce que vous avez peur des
critiques non non mais je les lis pas ah
bon oui est ce que vous avez peur de
prendre la parole devant une salle
entière oui oui bien sûr oui mais ça
veut pas dire que je suis pas capable de
le faire je vous le faites chef est ce
que vous avez peur de prendre l'avion
non de mois en mois enfin devant une
grande salle d'attentes certes mais
quand même c'est quoi que tu prends
l'avion
si vous avez peur des souris position
est ce que vous avez peur d'assumer vos
fantasmes
ah oui avec des sourires est ce que vous
avez peur de ne pas être à la hauteur
oui j'ai perdu 100 après tout même
contaminé c'est une question de
pollution
est ce que vous avez peur du noir du
vide pouvoir commencer à flipper et
d'anéantir 50 analyse avec un dieu le
travail vivant à table vides n'ont pas
peur je vous ai peur de manquer de
manquer non je crois pas non si vous
savez pas trop ce que ça veut dire c'est
que toi tu as peur de manquer bien sûr
comme tous les anciens peau est ce que
vous avez peur de l'anthrax non non pas
du tout l'entracte est ce que vous avez
peur de moi de vous mais pas vraiment je
vous fait plus peur non vous m'avez
jamais fait peur c'est de moi dont
j'aime peur avec panneaux bonnes
réponses
charlotte je vais vous laisser filer
parce que vous avez l'avant première de
votre film et pendant que vous avez
partir je vais montrer le cd parce que
la musique est géniale dans ce film
austin
j'ai montré le cd donc ça s'appelle ma
femme est une actrice divan attal avec
yvan attal et charlotte gainsbourg
et c'est à partir du 14 novembre dans un
cinéma près de chez vous merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant le règne des ouragans
mais là n'est pas le seul à y attendre
ici parce que manger un message à cuba
j'ai besoin d'argent
la lune est là la lunella la lunella
mais le soleil ne va pas on l'a prouvé
ouais si elizabeth teissier
oui
ces messieurs commence alors une entrée
un peu loupé la wii mais on fait la fête
comme celle figurant dans l'attenté du
monde 12 mai c'était ça la vérité mais
la vérité n'est pas toujours bonne à
dire
voilà comment est ma torche et voici
elizabeth teissier
et oui isabelle tessier vous avez
déclaré je suis la figure emblématique
de l'astrologie celle sur laquelle on
tire
et c'est vrai il est la cible des loges
et de critiques comme tous les gens qui
réussissent
vous êtes ici pour deux livres la
version expurgée de votre thèse qui fait
quand même six cent cinquante pages qui
s'appelle l'homme d'aujourd'hui et les
astres et puis votre horoscope 2002
c'est une tradition désormais chez
philippe paquet télé 7 jours qui
s'appelle l'année du défi dont vous êtes
obligé de faire deux fois pomme
je suis désolé je vous avais deux
produits avant dans lawrence tu peux
montrer c'est moi voilà c'est ça très
bien il à maître allons-y deux fois les
enfants ça c'est une fois c'est pour la
thèse maintenant fait pour l'horoscope
d'où ça vient ça 3 elle va refaire à ces
sucres de l'année qui a vacillé sur
temps sur 2003 ministre
non c'est superstitieuse par là dessus
il faut attendre d'y être à 2003
d'ailleurs on est en 2002 non plus bien
moins de ma torche et alors on commence
avec votre 2002 l'année du défi donc
chez philippe a quitté sept jours alors
que va-t-il se passer en 2002 eh bien on
peut dire en gros que ça va être un
petit peu le schéma inverse de celui de
cette année c'est à dire qu'on va manger
notre pain noir
au début et puis le pain blanc sera pour
le dernier trimestre concernent au dos
et ça
non mais qui qui disent les yeux
confirmé récession économique a tenté en
masse ces attentats en masse mais à
partir de septembre prochain
donc même si de ce cycle là devraient
déjà se terminer fin mai des jeunes
après les neiges vont repousser de tout
va ça peut-être mais la rentrée 2000
afin là encore 70 pensent qu'en france
ça sera un peu de désordre politique
encore à la rentrée là mais après ça se
calmer et l'année finit donc beaucoup
mieux qu'elle n'a commencé et la
récession sera commencera et à la
croissance reprendra pendant la ville
devenant son ballon pour le mois d'avril
qu'est ce qu'il va se passer non mais
comme c'est a priori faut regarder mais
je m'en veux plus y aller il faut
regarder il avait été scié pour vérifier
la fiabilité de vos prévisions et non
pas des prédictions oui je le dis pour
laurent qui sait pas très bien tout ça
j'ai retrouvé donc des anciennes
prévisions j'ai regardé si vous étiez
trompés ou pas d'en haut au scope 1987
vous aviez prévu le krach boursier bah
oui entre autres mais j'ai prévu plein
plein de choses mais pas tous la même
chose je vous dise plus ok ok long de la
saison je suis dans la fin du communisme
aussi avec six ou sept ans d'absolument
aux 80 de la vub autant c'est toi la
chute du mur de berlin lisabeth oulad
est prévue en 82 dans vos étoiles en
vous aviez prévu la guerre du golfe oui
la crise et la guerre après il ya eu une
révision dont suis assez fier parce
qu'elle n'était pas du tout linéaire est
pas évident puisque même les chauffeurs
de taxi me disais que me goure est
complètement c'était balladur je vais
manger j'ai dit que ce serait chirac et
musées mais non ce sera balladur au
premier tour
comment tuer on passe aux erreurs a
alors ça va être beaucoup plus long non
non
les clips de 11 autres 99 est prévue dès
4 ans en a vu des incendies des guerres
des krachs boursiers
vous dites vous avez dit non mais bon
j'ai dit oui ou non c'est donc le 11
août 99 il ya eu dix catastrophes mais
un seul oublié l'essentiel en tout cas
c'est que j'avais pris du leader j'avais
dit qu'il y aurait énormément de
catastrophe naturelle genre séisme et
trois aides encore dans paris match le
11 août ans le 8 août on le sait donc
non des séismes comme celui de turquie
il ya pas chaque année et surtout
sociale das naturelles dont la
championne est alors de visiter deux
séismes sont avec moi ça peut pas il
faut quand même dire une chose au sujet
du 11 août bon parce que il ya eu un
amalgame épouvantable et regrettable ban
on s'en souvient tous les deux après
vote plus que ça a sûrement pas parce
que justement lui même d'ailleurs disait
dans les ihm dans l'est
partout où il était invité que lorsqu'il
hésitation pour dater ces illuminations
bien y regarder dans les bouquins alors
comme honda a fait la malle gamme ça
s'était très vous avez bientôt ça va
quand même beaucoup parce que j'ai reçu
au moins 100 future de presse mme chaque
fois c'était comme comment dire dupont
et dupond tout va exploser le monde va
être plongée dans l'obscurité pendant
trois jours mais bon tant les annonces
assez vous confondre avec nostalgie je
n'ai pas cet honneur je ne suis pas
nostradamus n'ai jamais dit que le monde
serait plongé dans une note
non elisabeth j'essaie non non je suis à
peine il vous analysez vous exprimer
laisser leur part les sièges arrière
j'essaie de batik j'ai essayé d'être
objectif j'ai commencé par dire tout ce
que vous aviez réellement prévu alors
maintenant je regarde ce que vous avez
raté ne me dit pas non à chaque fois oui
mais c'est pas du tout mais je vous
laisse tout à fait dire simplement c'est
moins simple que ça vous aviez vu si je
me suis trompé jared tous ici oui s'il
ne se passe rien j'ai dit signe alors si
c'est la fin du monde non pas du tout je
n'ai jamais dit ça écoutez mon livre
s'appelait 1999 2004 alors je pouvais
pas prêts dans la fin du monde 2009 à
bord et tout ça est ridicule on va
laisser d'accord
on va laisser tomber c'est important
l'histoire de la fin du monde c'est
important parce que je n'ai jamais dit
que ça serait la fin du monde j'aurais
qu'on souligne bien sûr j'étais tout
pour nous ce sera un peu la sonede
analyse que j'ai jamais des champignons
60 ans si j'en fais trop jugement non
mais c'est très généreux il est toujours
géniale
alors donc on passe à une autre erreur
vous allez me dire c'est une vraie
erreur en mai 97 quand chirac avait
dissout l'assemblée nationale vous aviez
prévu la victoire de chirac vous aviez
dit pour chirac cette année c'est
presque un boulevard
il a été très bien inspiré de faire les
élections maintenant c'est vrai que
c'est en étant l'événement ce que je dis
c'est le départ de deux de son premier
ministre en revanche et ça personne ne
l'a jamais voilà je viens prévue au même
titre est bien prévu c'est chirac allait
regagner les législatives et qu'il
allait nommer comme premier ministre
léotard sarkozy ou je ne sais trop qui
finalement c'est la gauche qui a gagné
jamais donner de noms léotard ou sarkozy
mais jamais reçurent alors ça j'aimerais
que vous me donniez la précédant
l'événement du jeu et moi je vais vous
faxer dans l'événement du jeudi le fait
que j'ai annoncé à ce moment là que
le départ du train de mulhouse autre
exemple le 11 septembre 2001 vous
écriviez dans le risk of stars du
mercure saturne vous dites jours heureux
pour les transports oui je sais oui
alain papini sa presse et des transports
non mais attends
il faut dire les choses à manger pas du
tout calculé ça par rapport ce sont des
cols que je fais pour l'europe dans télé
7 jours pour la france la suisse et j'ai
pas regardé cette l'incidence du de la
constellation sur les états unis après
quand les événements c'est arrivé j'ai
très bien compris que le thème des états
unis et de bush était fortement agressé
par cette configuration c'est pour ça je
ne les ai pas compris en plus il ya
autre chose je sais que c'est difficile
à admettre cela mais si on se met sur
sirius et qu'on regarde un peu les
choses de haut comme l'astrologie le
fait et comme un capricorne cellulaire
non mais un capital
eh bien je sais que c'est ça va faire
beaucoup de signes a pas tenu compte des
etats-unis dans votre évidemment là
dedans non mais surtout ce qu'on peut
dire aussi c'est que justement si on
essaye d'être complètement en dehors de
tout de tout jugement de valeur et en
dehors des camps eh bien il ya des
choses qui ont réussi ce jour là au
niveau des voyages voyez ce que je veux
dire
ah oui tous les autres tous les autres
d'accord oui c'est une façon de s'en
sortir et n'ont signalé taux plein il ya
plein de l'avion qu'il est qu'ils sont
presque sûr il ya des acteurs pour
toujours des avions qui sait qu'on a une
pensée pour ceux qui atterrissent quand
même ce jour là alors maintenant on
passe on passe à votre thèse
l'homme d'aujourd'hui et les astres
fascination et rejet chez plon oui donc
au départ c'était s'appelait attention
situation épistémologique de
l'astrologie à travers l'ambivalence de
la fascination et du rejet dans les
sociétés post modernes en espagne auquel
faisait 900 pages en deux volumes
lorsqu'il faut dire elisabeth à c'est
qu'effectivement colbert à supprimer
l'enseignement de l'astrologie à
l'université en 1666 deux ans après la
bière et vous voulez les faire revenir
voilà votre idée c'est que l'astrologie
reviennent à l'université a commencé par
là par la sorbonne c'est ça dans votre
idée de faire revenir
l'astrologie à l'université vous avez
profité du soutien de françois
mitterrand qui était qui veut demander
conseil et on peut le dire la guerre du
golfe en discussion très loin il brille
un rendez vous très gentiment parce que
je les appelais juste avant noël et et
je lui ai demandé s'il pouvait faire
quelque chose pour moi je vais vous
obtenez un rendez vous avec la patronne
de la de la sorbonne secteur de
l'académie madame et chandon à salou
était hyper sympa et qui m'a dit
d'ailleurs selon elle me disait tel il
faudrait absolument rien trop dur en
tout cas l'histoire de l'astrologie
n'ont pas forcément la technique et la
pas pareil c'est pas le oui mais c'est
déjà quelque chose ah non c'est parce
que tu as fais toi tu te bats pour la
réintroduction de l'astrologie pas
l'histoire mais je n'ai pas réintroduit
j'ai fait une thèse de sociologie
attention j'aimerais bien qu'elle y fut
déchets d'ailleurs je les lui ai alors
et alors j'ai adoré 2 ou wii mais moi
j'ai la chance de recevoir les bouquins
avant parce que je collabore un peu
l'émission et j'ai trouvé ça passionnant
ou bien écrit et puis ces personnages
sont attachants logeme terran vous a
donné un coup de pouce pour la
soutenance de votre thèse en sociologie
dont vous êtes maintenant docteur en
sociologie à la sorbonne
voilà servir et alors donc il ya eu
effectivement comme vous le savez tout
un tas de protestation des sociologues
ont déclaré tous les contrôles ont sauté
c'est une braderie médiatique et non
mais c'est vrai moi j'étais un fusible
gt gt un fusible dans cette guerre qui
me dépassait complètement et en plus il
faut bien dire une chose absolument
scandaleuse c'est que d'abord il ya
aucun grand nom du sociologue qui c'est
qui a écrit quoi que ce soit contre ma
thèse au contraire alain touraine m'a
défendu défendu d'en faire une suite
d'accords est encore elisabeth et chez
moi je vais à écouter tout ce qu'on
voulait mais il ya quand même eu quatre
prix nobel
catherine entend-t-il de gamme quatre
prix nobel qui se sont insurgés qui ont
discuté scandale qu'elle vise à mettre
tessier puisse faire une thèse de
sociologie à la sorbonne et bien écoutez
savez ça l'est pas vous dîtes vous dit
vous vous répondez s'en sont allés voir
jacquelin vous répondez vous vous dites
que parmi les quatre hinault belle qui
se sont opposés à votre thèse à la
sorbonne vitesse de sociologie vous
étiez à aucun prix nobel de sociologie
non mais non seulement bien sûr mais de
façon il na pas mais pas de prix nobel
sociologie mais je veux dire il y avait
aucun sociologue et puis c'est pas
seulement ça c'est que tous ces gens il
faut quand même être un tout petit peu
avoir le bon sens de du paysan ces gens
là n'avaient absolument pas lu une ligne
de ma thèse toutes ces critiques voulait
dire quoi d'ailleurs ils s'en sont pas
cachés la fameuse la fisu savez cette
même temps vous allez me parler sûrement
et qui était mal si oui est-ce adaptons
tu te rends compte dont les deux ans
elle fait des prévisions c'est normal
qu'ils sont ce sont des fanatiques ce
sont les talibans de la culture ce sont
les gens qui sont d'une intolérance
totale par tous les cas il ya eu 400
articles dans la presse a fait un
scandale et beaucoup de genres gratuit
savez bien fou je regrette que vous et
le doctorat saison qui ne peut pas dire
autre chose
la maison-mère de maison mère dé oui je
les emmerde vas-y que je les emmerde
s'appelle en mer articule dit le forfait
je les emmerde
[Applaudissements]
oui
alors à parler de votre vie donc vous
êtes né à alger je ne dirais pas l'année
où tout le monde le sait c'est pas grave
ah bon merci janvier comme vous mon cher
6 janvier voilà deux jours que l'année
non tu vas pas le dire alors voilà alors
votre vrai nom c'est germaine hanselmann
nous alors là je suis ravi que vous
parliez de la tyrie parce que vraiment
j'en ai ras-le-bol de cette histoire bon
c'est vrai j'ai changé mon prénom à
l'âge de 20 ans tout le monde a le droit
mais je n'aimais pas gervais martel
souhaite être clair pour tous dit ouais
alors j'ai choisi elisabeth que j'aimais
bien jambes donc non j'aime tettey
semaine avec des mieux les tests
détectent et alors donc à 20 ans je suis
devenu quantité la sorbonne est marié
avec andré tessier ducrocq mais vous
êtes devenus la bête t60 les sirops et
les combinards matar et ceci étant vous
avait divorcé vous avait divorcé dans
notre dossier oui on vous appelez de
nouveaux germes annoncé demain et non
pas du tout parce que je de j'ai eu la
dispense du tribunal comme que j'étais
connu en tant que tessier oued pour
garder mon nom normalement vous devriez
vous reprendre votre nom de jeune fille
je pourrais de nos jours vous savez on a
les deux noms les femmes gardent les
deux n'ont en général
ouais donc votre vrai nom c'est quoi je
m'appelle germes l'église comme fait
hanselmann comme nom de jeune fille
tessier ducroux femmes mariées voilà il
divorce et ben voilà les divorces bien
alors votre père salué en elle même nuit
alors pour le doyen alors lui passé de
la malepère il n'avait pas le choix
j'ai tellement de bonne souche
spécialement froid oui un peu inhibés
bouleversée alors non mais très
protestant 20-13 suisse-allemand
protestants pas très tendres protestante
pic à 130 de sa marque
ces pages jaunes tombent sagement non
mais c'est pas il a aidé à vous et pas à
sauter sur ses genoux
c'étaient les capricornes ont souvent
une enfance un peu malheureux ouais non
il avait bonifié avec le temps il a
fallu du temps pour qu'il ait des gestes
de tendresse envers vous à 72 vers la
fin il a commencé à être un peu ton avec
vous non mais c'est vrai
votre merde son prénom c'était quoi
germaine encore valable c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs jamais compris mes parents
qui ont eu la bonne idée d'appeler mon
frère comme son père valter
et moi j'ai un peu quand on s'appelait
dans la famille comme si c'est pas très
bien armés et vous vous étiez une bonne
élève
vous étiez assez doué en classe au
paquet riz alors vos fiches très bonne
très bonne haleine et beaux-parents
voyez pas l'intérêt
jamais de vue que tu vas te marier
toutes manières à quoi ça sert ma mère
si oui alors vous avez une enfant cela
vous bouger beaucoup un pendant votre
enfance
oui mes parents avaient la bougeotte
deuxième où vous comprends oui d'accord
c'est pas des formalités
c'est pas vraiment la sellette chez
huawei alors donc berne casablanca puis
vous retournez en france
au collège dans la haute loire au
collège cévenol louis kotra tous les
fonds de partage au connaissent alors
nous pouvons vous atterrissez à paris
vous faites propédeutique à la sorbonne
et vous prépare une licence de lettres
et là un jour vous êtes en train de
boire un coup avec une copine place de
la sorgue et et boisons et là je vous
êtes place de la sorbonne donc vous
buvez un coup avec une copine il ya un
photographe qui débarque
oui et qui vous dit filion magnifique
j'ai pas vu son site et qui vous dit est
ce que vous allez faire des photos pour
moi d'abord là haut n'ont pas tort non
toi au moins tu parles on dit ça mais
sera un petit peu de beurre dans les
épinards parce que c'est vrai qu'avec
alain corneau avec à
mais en train de réaliser cet été vers
noël et c'est parce qu'il m'a déjà
demandé sa carte de visite parce que bon
draguer pas mal et j'ai demandé sa carte
de visite et c'est vrai qu'il était
c'était tout simplement commencer par la
couverture noël elle enchaînait que la
double page de lui oui je fais aussi des
journaux des photos pour lui oh la la
bon c'est pas grave et les moniteurs
vous dites ça mettra un peu de gorge que
ces épinards ouais c'est vrai
andré tessier ducrocq il était chasseur
d'étudier les jeunes étudiants et argent
alors on donnait d'ailleurs des cours
particuliers lui de mater et moi de
français et d'allemand mais c'était
quand même bonne société protestante a
quand même tout à fait polytechnique
donc là vous comprenez qu'il faut quand
même jeudi explique et les c'est là que
j'ai compris combien les neurones sont
moins apprécié que l'apparence physique
mois se traduise et des bouquins de
philo avec les pieds dans se suivent et
là l'exemple d'albert schweitzer que
j'avais lu que pourtant des tentes y
passer ses examens il mettait les pieds
dans l'eau froide pour pas s'endormir le
soir
et moi je faisais mes traductions les
pieds dans une bassine d'eau froide dans
ma chambre de bonne non mais c'est vrai
ayant et là j'ai réalisé qu'on eu une
matinée j'ai gagné ce que je gagnais en
un mois de traduction je suis dit le
monde n'est pas juste 26 ans 56 kg 1 m
75 vous devenez mannequin vous allez
travailler chez chanel et un jour
évidemment fait la boulette
vous faites une photo chez chanel avec
une robe à 69,95 dis donc elle précise
aussi les ans françois oui c'est alors
coco chanel faisaient des robes à 10 15
buts ben oui mon avis de droit
théoriquement pas le droit non écrit
mais elle avait du mal digéré son oeuf
ce jour-là elle vous a viré elle m'a
viré oui mais j'étais la dernière à être
viré de la cabine je croyais que j'étais
inamovible ouais pas du tout et là vous
vous dirigez vers le cinéma
vous faites un certain nombre de films
avec pas mal de grands réalisateurs
et fellini de sic à sydney pollack
évidemment frustration avec josé
bénazéraf oui bah ça oui bon c'est pas
très grave c'était un film aurait mieux
fait de ne pas le faire celui là parce
que vraiment parce qu'il était une cité
d'abord c'était pas du porno c'est non
non je tiens à dire des spectateurs non
pas du tout non justement c'est pour ça
qu'il ya eu une telle un tel malentendu
là dessus il faudrait quand même précisé
c'était d'une totale innocuité
c'était c'était vraiment écouter à tel
point que quand quand monsieur qui n'est
pas très élégant a profité de ma
notoriété lié à la publication du livre
sur mitterrand son lit son film n'ayant
ayant été un total four il faut le dire
25 ans avant 1 il a profité de ce succès
du livre en 97 pour sortir une cassette
il s'est dit je vais vous le mans filer
dans son sillage et puis bon je suis
passé dans penthouse quoi les photos ont
été publiées en bois les choses tout à
fait fausses sur moi y était vraiment
pourquoi parce que il a perdu 3 pouces
et que je lui ai fait ouais voilà alors
évidemment il m'en voulait il a
rencontré que des vaches milka ce film
permet de voir qu'elle est ce qu'elle
beauté vous étiez j'étais super rebelle
c'est pas du tout pour moi je tiens à
dire aux amis des spectateurs là c'est
pas la peine de vous ruer sur la
cassette de frustration de josé
bénazéraf temps dieu sait qu'on a fait
des gorges chaudes d'un film érotique
mais pas au graphique alors on peut leur
causer scène sur le plan tactique
c'était très joli bond et l'a donc après
tous ces grands réalisateurs et puis
benazerah vous avez un peu ras-le-bol de
tous ces mecs vous dites beaucoup de
promesses par des messieurs influents
qui me demandait à les voir et vous
refusez qui me montrait surtout c'était
surtout la promotion canapé là vous vous
révolter contre la promotion canapé et
là vous en avez assez du marché là
dedans way est là vos baisers debout
je devais penser à cela que vous avez
marre quoi ils voulaient tous vous
souhaitez en fait oui parce que en fait
je me suis souvent interrogé je me suis
dit d'où venait ce côté farouche et est
ce que c'est de la vertu non c'était
tout simplement de la fierté c'est toi
oui je voulais qu'on ne lance pas les
choses ouais voilà
hélas alors vous allez tourner un film
qui est sûrement votre plus gros navets
il faut bien le dire ces châteaux en
enfer ben oui c'est pas le mien c'est
celui de sydney pollack
bien sûr c'était pas là j'avais un si
petit rôle là dedans à lancaster mais ça
a été ma ma chance ça parce que j'avais
un contrat mirifique pendant six mois où
j'ai été merveilleusement payer en
yougoslavie à ne rien faire quelques
apparitions en plus le y avait une
scoumoune sur ce film absolument
épouvantable il aurait dû faire le thème
avant de commencer parce que le château
a brûlé il se disait en enfer oui ça
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais il avait
choisi la yougoslavie pourquoi parce
qu'il s'était basé sur des statistiques
météorologiques pour être sûr qu'ils
donnent quelques rues en hiver très long
jusqu'au mois de mai résultat des
courses ils n'avaient jamais fait aussi
beau au mois de février mars y avait des
bourgeons de partout ils ont dû mettre
de la neige artificielle c'était l'enfer
vraiment et la sntri l'astro voilà
fellini vous dit avant de partir en
porte un et d'astrologie et c'est comme
ça qu'il est devenu
c'est là que j'ai décidé d'aller d'être
de prendre des cours d'astrologie en
rentrant je me suis dit cinéma
ras-le-bol toute façon ça ne comblera
jamais ma soif de connaissance est
besoin que nous en fin mai mais le
besoin d'activités de mes neurones mais
j'avais besoin de travailler avec ma
tête est bien que je regrette aussi
l'image aimerait bien enfin ça c'est un
appel au peuple et donc les matches
là je retrouvais ton esprit bélier alors
ils ont dans un jour c'est vrai je m'en
fous tout dire pas mais l'amour du
métier mais je m'en branle mon vieux os
alors il avait été scié j'ai une idée je
vous ai demandé de préparer une
interview deux mois à partir de mon
thème astral et ça s'appelle l'astro
view
[Applaudissements]
joseph thierry ardisson alors moi
contrairement à vous évidemment je n'ai
pas été chercher des infos particulière
parce que vous vous savez tout sur les
gens moi au contraire je reste dans
l'innocence entre guillemets alors dites
que vous ne direz que la vérité toute la
vérité je dirai que la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité moi il faut
cracher pour valider le serbe décroche
alors né le 6 janvier
oui à quoi s'était engagé à dire la
vérité donc batailler patate chaude à
toi là tu as des couilles comme kepler
comme adriano celentano comme diane
keaton comme à l'endroit et marie myriam
avec qui avez-vous le plus d'affinités
de ses personnages jeanne d'arc
pourquoi est ce que j'entends des voix
moi aussi mais dans mon oreillette alors
le le capricorne est un animal ambitieux
oui
alors jusqu'où ira votre ambition
thierry jusqu'à faire ce que je veux
faire depuis que suis tout petit c'est
écrire des livres ne faire que ça j'en
ai fait quelques-uns mais il faudrait
vraiment que ça alors qu'il vous attend
verts 66 cents à 66 ans revient à marc
tessier
je viens michèle cotta dont vous m'avez
jusqu'à 60 francs ça va vous allez voir
leur compte
70 ans non mais vous avez rite alors
pourquoi la capricorne est avec le lion
le signe par excellence de la politique
alors est ce que pour vous avez été
tenté j'avais jamais été tenté par la
politique c'est producteurs à la
télévision c'est très politique c'est
vrai bon alors votre ascendant gémeaux
qui est un signe donc comme vous savez
s'exprime à travers une dualité alors
juste une vive et se dit à lutter plus
tôt sur le plan politique entre la
droite et la gauche sur le plan du
travail à la fois on vous êtes à la fois
autocrate et maso ou sexuelle est
inutile de faire un dessin
non alors je le vis sur le plan du
caractère c'est à dire je suis
extrêmement cyclothymique
à certains moments très joyeux comme un
fait grave
voilà ça c'est possible on va
complètement oui complètement
et est ce que vous êtes influencé à
prendre souvent l'ascendant j'aime ou
quand il ya le chauffeur de mitterrand
qui me dit que j'avais couché avec le
président je suis à ses influences
j'ai vu leurs deux mitterrand tout à
fait gémeaux ça c'est pas bien mais
lorsqu il impressionnait c'est qu'il a
montré des photos ça ça m'étonnerait
bon alors un trait caractéristique du
capricorne c'est son good pour la vérité
oui ça va alors chez vous cette
recherche d'absolu et quelque peu comme
voilées ou déviés comment ressentez-vous
sa part un itunes obscurci pour que
toutes les vérités ne sont pas bonnes à
dire malheureusement et des choses qu'on
peut pas dire mais j'essaie d'en dire le
plus possible disant je suis le moins
menteur ce même aspect il s'agit en
l'occurrence de soleil neptune qui chez
vous est exact est révélateur d'une
nature d'une problématique avec le père
est probablement liée à cela un goût de
la fuite qui est peut-être à l'origine
la recherche des paradis artificiels et
moi je dirais que ça remonte à 17 ans ou
autour de 17 ans et 21 ans
c'est très juste aux 34 non je suis
parti de chez moi à 16 ans effectivement
parce que je m'entendais pas bien avec
ma famille à l'époque ça a changé depuis
eh ben pour fumer des pétards oui mais
voilà bon et 21 ans qu'est ce qui s'est
passé par rapport à ça là j'ai essayé
d'autres dauplat j'ai dû prendre c'était
la cie de cette époque là alors avec la
sentence gémeaux et le milieu du ciel en
verseau vous êtes et vous avez en plus
une construction solide jupiter qui est
celle du succès qu'est celle du succès
le secteur du public est très très
puissant vous êtes fait pour communiquer
mais la provocation
bon après vous avez un esprit très
acérées vif inventif pas vraiment
puisque cette alerte rouge à temps mais
attendent autre chose
polémique original vous auriez pu être
avocat avec cette conjonction la parole
de la défense qui peut être assez
systématique
c'est vrai tout ça mais qui peut être
systématique voire agressif et qui ce
qui peut d'ailleurs vous aliéner des
amitiés naissent vrai ah oui ça j'ai
plein d'amitié aliéner la or votre
évolution passe nécessairement par
l'amitié à la cedh important à savoir
votre évolution spirituelle passe par
l'amitié alors amour et travail sont
liés
vous créez des liens affectifs dans le
contexte professionnel
c'est vrai je fais pas de différence
entre ma vie privée et ma vie
professionnelle
ouais ouais mais on voit nettement les
deux centres de vouvoyer seuil et abat
complètement vous avez venus que n'a
fait la moue toit de sa gueule toi
tout le monde doit tirer à tout le monde
le voit c'est très très visible fille
toi moi maintenant connais pas mais pas
du tout elle sait que tu fais que bosser
donc tu vois les gens dans le boulot
mais ça ça c'est les conclusions idiote
alors
donc moi je vais bien tu me parles comme
tu sais pas tu t'habilles en cuir ma
grande parce que l'adversaire
qui est vraiment très bon les femmes
sont comme un mal nécessaire vous les
idéaliser elle vous perturbe
bref vous êtes un brin miso quand même
quelques pas est ce vrai l'heure des
filles un peu vain il est lille et
honnête c'est ça s'était très capricorne
dommage car elle vous ressources les
bonnes femmes en plus vous risquez de
rencontrer une femme très riche sur le
tard aulas
merci va s'en sortir les 36 37 ans a une
vie d'année très importante
est ce que gérard plein de gonzesses et
gagner dupont aignan depuis ce printemps
jusqu'à l'année prochaine vous êtes dans
une phase de doute perturbant
perturbateurs vous êtes dans un doute
existentiel presque vous remettez en
question beaucoup de cheveux ouais ça va
bien c'est vrai c'est bien géré même
alors il ya deux questions une question
qui tue la première physique la deuxième
mi temps la question qui tue attention
mesdames messieurs robin sont coincés
sur son île choisissez vous pour
vendredi plutôt un beau noir athlétique
ou un laideron plein de boutons une nana
sentant un beaunois critiques non la
gare la métaphysique carton qui tue
métaphysique deuxième question qui tue
alors la question métaphysique si
méphistophélès vous donne vous promets
l'accès aux vérité ultime au sens de la
vie à la connaissance absolue contre la
gloire égotiste des médias l'obscurité
cathodique qu'est-ce que vous choisissez
alors maintenant que j'ai connu la
lumière des médias je choisis pour la
vérité mais c'est très bien
messieurs
besson
et du défi
hello
c'est chez plon mesdames messieurs
j'accueille maintenant au rwanda
orlando bonsoir soir alors en fait vous
appelez bruno gigliotti guignols qui
veut dire le lis exact voilà alias
orlando et vous êtes le frère cadet de
dalida dont vous avez été le producteur
de 1970 à 1980 sert aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui vous êtes son légataire 1 en
fait
orlando s'est pas votre vrai nom c'est
nom de votre frère aîné exact vous vous
appelez bruno donc c'est la soirée c'est
à dire que l'elizabeth s'appelle german
brass et moreno way
vous c'est effectivement donc bruno et
vous avez prises ce pseudo d'orlando les
emprunter au moment où vous êtes venu en
france dans les années 60 trois 64 alors
avant d'être en france des tirs l'egypte
1 au caire dans le quartier de choubra
votre père qui s'appelait pietro était
violoniste à l'opéra du caire et votre
mère giuseppina s'occuper de la maison
voilà donc ça met du quartier de choubra
votre père est mort à ces jeunes très
jeunes je les vois pratiquement pas
connu
est ce que c'est parce que pendant la
guerre en tant qu'italien mussolinien il
avait été arrêté par les anglais au
caire où il a dit que tous les italiens
avaient été internés à cette époque là
dans un raid comme après décompte des
centres concentration je me rappelle
très bien que lever toutes les femmes
des internats italien de reprendre un
autobus vers 3 4 heures du matin dans un
de vos spéciale du caire et tout le
monde monte pour arriver à fayed c'était
fayed l'école et fayed
ça devait être loin seulement parce que
l'on ne partait très tôt pour arriver en
avait dix jours 19 heures du matin et
voltaire penser que c'est ça qui l'a tué
son incarcération et les sorties les
morts tout de suite moins c'est ça alors
dalida elle avait très peu connue aussi
elle croyait qu'elle l'aimait pas son
père et ont peut-être que sa quête
d'hommes pendant toute sa vie peut-être
c'est justement pour remplacer son père
pascal à travers tous les hommes de sa
vie elle a recherché le père ouais elle
voulait sublimer le super malgré
quelques courriers qui n'aimait pas du
tout et alors ces mots là ils se
trouvaient les hommes à leur plus haut
les places et pour deux ans elle est
tombée quentin chercher inaccessible et
accessible absolue à semble donc vierge
très torturée la la alors vous passez
votre adolescence en egypte où vous
chanter c'est vous qui avez créé
mustapha j'étais un adolescent mustapha
ça a été un beau bazar c'est un succès
énorme
bah oui alors milieu des années 60 vous
débarquez à paris pour réussir vous
aussi une carrière dans la chanson comme
comme votre soeur qui était déjà une
star elle en fait au départ au caire
elle voulait être secrétaire et puis
elle a eu un problème aux yeux elle
avait tu es tombé d'une maladie d'hôtel
ni au caire que c'était une maladie
courante au caire et le docteur a fait
une énorme faute lui a bandé les yeux
pendant 40 jours et quand on a enlevé le
bandage et les who qui louche était
normal oui ma mère c'était vanille mon
père voulait tuer comme a raconté bien
sûr je t'ai pas mon père voulait tuer
les docteurs on la halle est opéré à
trois ans est notre s'étend et donc et
après la portée et ça l'obligé à porter
des lunettes
jusqu'à l'âge de 15 saisons ouais et ça
veut dire quelqu'un quelque sorte et et
nice et rémy en place tout de suite le
deuxième avait gardé une certaine
faiblesse
et puis comme s'il avait une revanche à
prendre dans la vie elle qui pensait
qu'elle était laide et fils à mesure
qu'ils grandissent et les formes se
former commencez à voir que le regard
changé et puis un jour elle a pris ses
lunettes elle a dit les agités par la
fenêtre n'est jamais plus je porterai de
lunettes
1 et elle s'est présentée au concours à
l'époque de miss ondine avant de se
présenter trois ans plus tard la miss
egypte pour se prouver à elle-même comme
un défi que les prévenus belle mais elle
a gagné à sa grande surprise elle a
gagné le prix la presse a publié les
photos de dalida en maillot sauf un
scandale dans la famille dans la famille
est ce qu elle le dira ensuite elle
travaille dans une maison de couture
chez daunat où elle apprit le métier de
mannequin et en 54 donc elle devient
dalida miss egypte elle commence à faire
un peu de cinéma et c'est là que son
destin va se jouer parce que dans la
salle il y avait trois hommes 1
il y avait metteur en scène égyptien et
metteur en scène français marc de gay
marié de gastines et mettre en scène la
américaine qui tournait à l'époque le
film joseph et ses frères alors ces
trois hommes et le metteur en scène
égyptienne va la faire jouer dans un
film où il doit jouer lé rôle d'une
italienne qui vend plein docteur lê le
français va l'amener en haute egypte
c'est comme ça que dalida va découvrir
la terre des pharaons
et pour être une espionne une sorte de
mathari dont les masques dane cameron et
l'américain va l'amener aussi en haute
egypte pour faire la doublure de révolte
ensuite à john collins mais voilà et l'a
donc marque de gastines l'a fait venir
en france et elle prend l'avion c'est
insensé de 24 décembre 54 avec vingt
mille francs de l'époque en poche et
deux ans après elle fait les numéros 1
de demain à l'olympia dans la salle il
ya là aussi encore une fois trois hommes
l'oiseau moqueur qui décide de sa
destinée trois hommes à paris bruno
coquatrix qu'il ouvrira les portes de
l'olympia lycée maurice qui va
l'annoncer qui deviendra son époux eddie
barclay qui va lui signer un contrat qui
n'ont qu'à trop vite c'est jusqu'à 14
ans et quand elle le quittera définitive
quand on décidera de les quitter ce
serait pas une infidélité
parce que l'heure a été fidèle pendant
14 ans et ensuite c'est pas qu'ils
valent et dont j maisons concurrentes
parce qu'on a offert dix ont des cachets
faramineux ou des primes et le montrer
avec moi est sa propre maison sera le
premier producteur indépendant donc
voilà laurent vous voulez vous les a
répétés là oui je vais le répéter mais
je voulais qu'on parle de michaël blanc
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure
oui je vais mons est d'or et mentor je
vais les mettre aux enchères sur
internet de façon à ce que l'argent de
la vente du 7 d'or soit pour nous caler
ben écoute moi je ferais déjà dit mille
pour le 7 d'or noir
c'est une première enchère merci laurent
n'est ce pas
donc vous vous n'avez pas le succès
escompté dans la chanson en france et
vous décidez de vous occuper d'elle en
67 vous rentrez chez barclays et vous
devenez son directeur artistique après
vous monter une boîte international show
et de gérard landau production après et
vous vous occupez d'être c'est un des
premiers producteurs indépendants en
france
vous lancez aussi les vagabonds indra et
maintenant hélène ségara il ya une
mélodie aussi mes échecs mais logique
jadot absolument acquis et tout ça est
absolument ils ont la perle dix ans de
l'écurie sellin ségala bien sûr
justement pourquoi vous êtes le
producteur de ce producteur dr secka
pourquoi vous refusez quelqu'un dans
cette émission mais je ne refuse pas ma
tante et au jet de bien raison vous
m'avez donné la vitre les jours david
hâle est dans une très bonne raison
excusez moi que je sais que la peur
l'autre soir la première question que
vous avez posé à alain alors à quel âge
vous avez fait et maintenant je vais
demander ça s'est réglé pourquoi mon nom
elle viendra en temps voulu vous savez
c'est pas vrai vous êtes quand vous que
je pêche parce que ces genres
d'émissions je perds deux fois que les
artistes peuvent déraper voilà qu'elle
se lâche bien jeter les mauvais
souvenirs de la télévision je sais pas
si c'est pour ça que je suis sur mes
gardes savions plus qu est ce qui vous
était arrivé quelques souvenirs je vais
pas revenir on se rappelle tous de cette
fameuse émission le jeu de la vérité
oui avec quelqu'un vous savez que juste
un mot ça avait suffi une soirée et mots
qui était passé à côté pour longchamp
verrouillage sabatier je ne connais pas
le nom mais là le mec que j'aime
beaucoup derrière je me souviens
passagers bien et que quand même ça mis
en danger selon hélène ségara je vous
invite officiellement dans quinze jours
dans cette édition
pourquoi avec elle ni moi je vis à vis
de la sopab de vous tenez je sais je
sais tout à fait d'ailleurs j'en suis
tout à fait apte à fait conscient donc
aujourd'hui en l'an 9 êtes le légataire
de dalida
alors évidemment il ya deux versions de
vos activités il ya ceux qui disent que
vous faites une exploitation éhontée de
ses tubes en faisant des remixes divers
et variés à toutes les sauces
et puis à votre
attention à vous qui dit je ne veux pas
qu'on enferme dalida dans un sarcophage
en faisant des remixes chaque dépense du
poids new way
parce que si je voulais faire de
l'argent je n'avais qu'à vendre les
version originale tard il faut passer
maintenant de la version originale de
resteront toujours et pour l'éternité
c'est celle qui se vendent le plus est
que les gens recherchent les phénomènes
de mixage ces deux phénomènes demande
des trois ans à tous a dit que tous les
proches d'entre 14 j'ai créé une
actualité autour de l'oeil dalida pour
la fixer les tubes de l'année d'avant
l'ère du moment où je peux pas oublier
carré d'as et pas simplement une artiste
c'est la menthe ou master 2 mais en
aucun cas je voudrais trahi ça alors là
il ya un nouveau remix donc ils
s'appellent c'est comment on fait avec
les mains orlando de la révolution c'est
une manière
[Musique]
dany
m
[Musique]
non
moi je dis
[Musique]
je viens j'ai appris à vie
j'avais lu
[Musique]
non
m
l'état
[Musique]
cerrone une chanson
vivant aux landaus
les luttes moitié franchi comme vous
voyez star oui ça me fait pas plaisir de
la voir si vivante éclatante de beauté
des bonheurs sessad aridha c'est pour ça
que dalida elle est ce qu'elle est alors
hollande où on l'a dit tout à l'heure
dalida chercher un peu son père à
travers les hommes dont il est lucien
morisse qui était le directeur
artistique d'europe 1 qui s'est suicidé
quand même oui mais quand il faut
remettre les choses à leur place quand
il se suicider et il ne vivait plus avec
dalida ça faisait déjà 10 ans qui
s'étaient séparés même s'il a toujours
été amoureux des alida alors elle l'a
quitté pour jean sobieski cette équipe
j'en dis est ce qu il faut se mettre
cette femme n'était arrivé il n'avait
qu'une idée en tête réussir et ne penser
qu'à réussir et la capacité pour réussir
toute sa vie elle était disons jusqu'à
qu'elle arrive à être dalida elle s'est
mariée et le disons que l'amour avec lui
si elle avait vécu avant de se marier et
lime et pendant cinq ans et un moment
que son mari elle n'émet plus elle y
avait dit bon c'était comme une sorte de
reconnaissance mais de façon cet amour
et cette amitié ça ne montrera jamais
être dans le haut rhin et la lutte
contre ce garçon festival de cannes
c'était lui c'est maurice était débarqué
qu'elle était partie des crédits et
nicole berkeley l'époque et a eu le coup
de foudre parce qu'avec cet ange blond
d'une grande beauté comme naujac
simulateur c'est vrai que là il a
toujours regretté par la suite train
alors il y avait aussi après jean ce
biais ski et luigi tenco qui était un
chanteur italien qui avait écrit avec
elle une chanson pour le festival de
chanson de san remo où ils ont défendu
ensemble agents défendu ensemble la
chanson beïda qui était déjà comme une
grande star détester les festivals et
l'a été par amour elle simplement pour
défendre sa chanson pour le lancer un et
lui qu'ils ont fait dix ans que la
chanson est éliminé il s'est senti en
quelque sorte un peu responsable par la
hauteur bien sûr et alors
et c'est aïda qu'elle compte il est
éliminé il est rentré à l'hôtel et s'est
suicidé c'est d'akela que la trouvait
bien sur la tête traumatisme a exhorté
dans son thème sont possibles c'est une
fatalité d'un fonds aia mais elle
d'ailleurs elle a fait une longue série
de tentatives de suicide
dalida
elle a tenté de mettre fin à ses jours
et mois après jour pour jour après
qu'elle a découvert le gîte en cause son
fiancé mans et elle s'est suicidée et
l'attenté de ce système est pour elle
dit toujours qu'elle était morte quand
elle avait sa première tentative de
suicide après celui de luigi tenco elle
est restée longtemps dans le coma elle
restait six jours elle est ensuite il a
été trois mois là parce que vous savez
que peut-on donné qu'elle a été
découvert au terme il avait tout le
monde j'imagine ce que vous savez
qu'elles sont son talon qui était posée
par terre à la une nécrose du talon il a
fallu prendre de la peau dans son pubis
pour refaire son exactement bravo alors
il ya eu aussi le comte de saint germain
richard chanfray vous dire qu'elle est à
les accumuler quand même votre soeur non
vous savez qui je pense une chose qui a
des destins celui gones c'est un tifo
dire à nos amis téléspectateurs les plus
jeunes
il disait qu'il était immortel enfin
créera pas bon extravagant mais bon vous
savez ce qui est devenu aujourd'hui il
après vous voyez qu'elle sait il n'est
pas immortel puisqu'il est mort il est
mort a lui aussi hérité rester quoi
l'histoire landau parce que visa bête on
l'a accusé d'avoir eu des des relations
coupables avec françois mitterrand il a
connu et
françois mitterrand et toute sa famille
ensuite en 1974 et d'aller y avait une
concrète du parti socialiste sont de
chair gaston déferré à marseille ont
invité des leaders à dîner - voilà
faut-il plus peut-être fait il me dit
que c'est environ loin il aimait les
belles femmes et donc je la seule chose
que davide rigon les a dit qu'il je
pense que il s'est arrangé pour que
gaston defferre invite dalida elle
qu'elle n'avait pas l'habitude du fatah
est tenu de son tour de chant et le
parterre l'hôtel si elle a dit est ce
que ce serait pas mal si vous venez
dîner avec nous ce soit donc c'est une
patrouille a pas eu de franchement ça je
ne pourrai pas de répondre
malheureusement n'est plus là pour le
dire et moi vous savez comme je dis
toujours j'aimerais toujours bord de la
porte je vais jamais la porte quand je
ne suis pas et je peux vous faire dire
ce que voulait pas dire mais un
mitterrand mitterrand avait quand même
rendre visite et des leaders dans la
maison de mon mars mais beaucoup de
monde non mais il se retrouver tous les
deux auraient besoin de moments il a
écouté
pourquoi vous voulez toujours voir
quelque chose rien c'est comme ça que
j'y fais pas un salaire mais vous savez
ce soit une fugue excuses
orlando vous êtes un producteur du show
business et vous ne serez pas étonné que
nous vous fassions une interview
moralité on a vu jusqu'à maintenant les
gens ne bougent pas pendant le génial on
à gauche par pendant le jingle bravo
merci alors à l'époque où vous habitiez
au caire dans le quartier de choubra est
ce que il vous est arrivé de piqué dans
le porte-monnaie de votre maman juice
épines
oui oui mais de petites choses comme
petit piastres ouais mais bon c'est déjà
une habitude qui ne l'ont pas du tout
non non non pas du comportement et
ouvert qui avait une petite pièce qui
tenait comme ça je voulais pas lui faire
de la peine
vous gagnez vous gagner au loto vous
gagner au loto
le billet ne vous appartient pas qu'est
ce que vous faites chez les gens tout de
suite
alors là c'est clair et net donc un
match superbe et généreux d'accord
orlando vous trouvez un porte monnaie
dans la rue avec de l'argent dedans
est-ce que vous rendez les papiers
et daniel elena moi même au commissaire
âge je dirais à une des amies on devrait
donc aller pour tester pour thomas n'ya
non ça m'intéresse pas d'accord vous
êtes plein de blé en même temps non il
ya donc un commerçant se trompe en vous
rendant la mener est-ce que vous lui
fait remarquer oui je peux vous regardez
moi dans les yeux quelqu'un at il
entendu les lignes 6 et alors si c'est
un commerçant que vous aimez pas dans un
quartier vous n'allez jamais évidemment
votre boulanger vous dit bonjour tous
les matins éléments voulus dit de
regarder vous êtes trompés dans
l'immédiat je voudrais pas le faire
maintenant ensuite je le ferai oui oui à
60 ans ma mère à quoi bon j'en fais
alors je peux le faire je dis ce que je
pense en face à salé capable est ce qui
vous arrive de faire les poches de la
personne avec qui vous vivez franchement
soyez avertis soyez pas étonné voilà je
n'ai pas l'habitude de les faire mais
fois j'ai les faits voilà je n'ai alors
vous êtes vous avec ce qui se passe je
sers été par la suite voilà dans ces cas
là ce qui est terrible c'est qu'on tombe
sur des numéros + une fois après on
appelle encore la banque se trompe de
dix mille francs en votre faveur
voilà vous recevez votre relevé de
banque et vous comprenez qu'il ya dix ou
cent mille loin millions est ce que vous
appelez la banque horizon vous êtes
trompé de toute façon je ne dirai rien
parce que toute façon il vaut son
entreprise alors il faudrait que tu fais
pas les mêmes à langer qui lui au moins
je l'espère caen table le plaisir
simplement qu'ils se sont trompés et si
l'employé qui a fait d'erreurs qui est
un père de famille qui gagne sept mille
francs par mois il a trois enfants il
est viré à cause de ça le grand plat
toute façon si c'était ça dans les
médias de façon qu'il ya une chose que
même si nous sommes trompés de laisser
traîner semaine après mois maximum après
bien sûr ça va ça va de soi mais même ça
va tout ça mais toute façon c'est rare
une scène que jamais c'est ça oui c'est
une maison
quelques chaînes de l'esprit alors voilà
imaginez vous possédez un appartement
qui vous appartient vous le loup et je
vous ai pas envie d'y habiter et le
locataire ne peut plus payer le loyer
c'est un type horrible vraiment c'est un
type détestable il a deux gosses
insupportable il peut plus payer le
loyer sa femme vous incite chaque fois
qu'elle vous voit est ce que vous le
foot est dehors
je pense que ouais vous le film insultes
je serai maso à la à la rigueur je
prendrais enfants je ne sais pas
j'appellerai quelqu'un pour qu'ils
s'occupent des enfants non plus les
enfants m'insulte aussi aux salades
alors il ya une histoire terrible je
vous fait la une des médias est en
couverture de france-soir du parisien du
figaro de tous les canards parce que
vous avez sauvé une petite fille d'un
incendie est en fait vous savez bien que
c'est pas vous qui l'avait sauvé que le
pompier qui l'a sauvée il est mort le
pour brûlé carbonisé terrible est ce que
vous dites est ce que vous dites vous
êtes trompé que ce n'était pas moi
ou est ce que vous dites bon je suis en
couverture du journal sur un héros après
tout merde j'ai l'habitude de ne pas
t'être couverture moment dernière page
va pas besoin de ça mais c'est la
moindre des choses serait de rendre
justice surtout quelqu'un qui est mort
comme thériault ma vie voir le pauvre
combiné cab le géant bancaire pour sa
famille on montrera qu'il est mort pas
pour les moins onéreux d'accord donc
vous êtes assez quand même pour un
producteur je veux dire c'est un
producteur ce sont des gens très bien
sûr je connais pas
lorsque nous tout le monde le sait mais
alors un mec vous a doublé sur
l'autoroute en vous humiliant je dirais
vous a fait en passe en effet comme ça
là et là elle a dit vous a doublé puis
bon et vous le retrouvez vous le
retrouver après après la sortie de
l'autoroute vous le retrouvez sur une
route départementale en panne
est ce que vous vous arrêtez pour le
secours et peut-être que je suis l'un
des commandites grossier je m'arrêterai
pas mais je me retrouverais quelqu'un
d'autre ou java j'appelle est pour dire
je n'aime pas perdre que moi même je ne
ferai pas question difficile
vous trouvez un nourrisson abandonné sur
votre paillasson chez vous et alors vous
l'adoptez ou si leur folie n'a fait quoi
difficile mais pour adopter un enfant
c'est une énorme responsabilité vous
savez il faut s'en occuper
en plus je sais pas si je serais si
j'espère une bonne peut-être mieux pour
lui de vivre avec vous qui est
financièrement assez aisée on peut lui
être quand même il peut aller à l'école
il peut faire alors que sinon c'est leur
folie non non non c'est trop facile de
répondre comme ça parce qu'on est à la
télévision de durno je répondrais g à dr
et c'est pas vrai je veux pas répondre
ça d'abord je n'ai pas été confronté le
problème à l'engager pas même si je la
mettrais quelque part ça c'est réfléchi
à cela les dvd salle où le temps vient
de moi dire de dire une maison pour
faire bien dire oui je l'avais la
docteure je ne sais pas je peux pas vous
chasser les esprits chercher des excuses
blessé tout seul à l'orphelinat ont pas
tout seul pas tout seul enfin oui tout
ça alors que le racing dans les cas
plusieurs félins donc ils sont plus
on
monsieur
mission
et maintenant
eh oui
[Musique]
voici titoff
à
pour l'heure comment ça va ça va gso my
way et en sortir soit même pas tu sais
ma sortie je suis battu toi tu m'a
appelé ouais n'était pas sorti non et
toi par contre un peu la fille avec qui
tu étais le toit ce qui est magnifique
t'as vu ouais c'est ma soeur non c'est
qui c'est une amie une amie way avait
bien et très bien mais l'état français
savait quoi l égyptienne ah ben voilà tu
vois orlando il connaît il a dit en
egypte au caire tome clôt de façon
landouge gms comment je vais je arriver
je crois que c'était michou
avant le tournoi ça réducteur mais mardi
10 ans était bien dans l'est dans les
jeux les choses là le film oui j'ai vu
l'autre fois parce que je regarde
l'émission
ouais c'est bien mais des fois je viens
parce que je me dis de là on la voit
encore mieux si ça se passe bien il est
bien le fils très bien voyagé je vais
les choses de gilles paquet brenner
titoff way qu'est ce tu fais la fille
gens qui le comprend
[Applaudissements]
moi je vais tenir à l'oeil on n'aura
jamais et c'est bien là c'est clair
j'ai mes raisons non à jamais ces gars
mais c'est du cinéma
oui c'est vrai ils sont liés comme ça et
quoi dix mois elle a tourné à la super
super super bon bah tu sais comment on
fait non dis moi j'ai reçu un e-mail
d'une gonzesse qui s'appelle laura
souchard de tours tu t'en souviens
non j'étais pt
sinon ce soit dit thierry pour étudiera
titoff que je laime à moi il faut que je
réfléchisse un peu que non c'est très
gentil merci mais de tous je me rappelle
alors dit non je suis sur internet j'ai
vu un truc très rigolo là c'est quoi
tout où vous allez mettre des petits
trucs comme ça sur le site
c'est tombé sur moi sur la webcam ouais
c'est des petits
c'est une petite webcam enfin confère la
maison oui oui donc voila vous allez
voir ma salle de bain et c'est des
petites rues bc wasquehal c'est aussi ça
le niveau à grammont ce film fait je me
film c'est une webcam sur son maintien
[Applaudissements]
au départ la musique
je me suis pas fait compris et je vais
laisser tomber ça je me sens très près
ce que je ne sais quoi c'est triste
quand tu veux dire
[Musique]
je suis compétiteur
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien ouais et puis alors bientôt
il ya ça il ya le 1
bambi scemama quelques emails poursuivre
avec julie piva de ceinture qui me dit
je fais appel à toi pour le message
suivant
ok christophe et moi c'est son jules
sommes heureux d'annoncer que nous
attendons un bébé si tu passes message à
l'antenne on l'appellera thierry sinon
on appellera marc olivier
là j'ai passé alors il ya vincent
bruyère qui dit tout simplement je
voudrais dire un prof d'allemand que je
m'emmerde voilà c'est tout et on arrive
à michaël blanc michaël blanc c'est ce
garçon qui est en taule à bali à
perpétuité pour des chips
c'est énorme c'est un à perpétuité toute
sa vie jusqu'à saint pas faire quelque
chose on va faire quelque chose déjà
vous pouvez envoyer des chèques de 1
franc ou de 1 euro c'est encore mieux
en tous les cas moi j'ai décidé de
vendre 7 d'or et moi hot d'or voilà donc
fait les offres est ce que c'est une
question d'argent est ce qu'avec a de
l'argent on arrivera très bon bakchich
râler mais qui le tiennent en taule la
base c'est comme ça que ça se passe
donc ce 7 d'or voilà vous pouvez la voir
chez vous il suffit de faire des
enchères sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
alors ben fille d'un de ses amis diminue
donc 90
d'abord timide et a mis dix mille moi je
mets 9000
c'est quoi ça sert d'or c'est aussi
apprendre dans mes sémiologue d'or ces
cinq hommes mine d'or c'est encore plus
beau c'est un joli cci this c'est l'avis
d'anciens beaucoup plus un mode de
recommencer d'orgueil parce que je les
gagne et moi même
et maintenant
[Musique]
à
pourquoi si philippe duc
m
messieurs oh là là oh mon pauvre twitter
alors oui bonsoir bonsoir thierry et il
avait été scié voilà qui est mise dans
l'illustré parfaitement moi aussi entré
dans la légende
voilà orlando frère de l'abonné nous
nous sommes rencontrés il ya pas
longtemps sur le plateau pour la
spéciale hélène ségara j'ai vu m segarra
vous oui le peuple a donné un landau
c'est plus facile chez drucker et les
plus calmes 14 bonsoir bonsoir tire donc
vous êtes dans on a tout essayé de temps
en temps quand michel drucker vous vous
laisse vous échapper de vivement
dimanche prochain
voilà je suis en lire en liberté
surveillée roger pénitentiaire chez
drucker et je peux parfois à les faire
on a tout et je remercie michel michel
si je vous regarde
merci il venait à laisser de temps en
temps philippe geluck
alors vous avez déclaré toute façon une
vache qui passe à la télé c'est une
vraie star mais c'est quand même qu'une
vache
donc vous n'êtes pas dupes de votre
notoriété télévisuelle ni de la vôtre
il a bien bien sûr il ya une autorité
célébrités 1
c'est françois giroux qui disait ça
allait s'arrêter sur l'autre chose c'est
johnny ce sont les plats pour nous c'est
celle de la notorité ça permet d'avoir
plus facilement une place au restaurant
oui hein c'est ce qui est dit dans ma
femme est une actrice très bien divers
ça permet des petites choses agréables
comme ça ça permet de d'attirer
l'attention sur vous quand vous
vous écrivez un livre quand nous publier
quelque chose quand vous sortez un
disque alors c'est parfois fait avec un
certain bonheur est parfois moins comme
certains animateurs dont nous ne
parlerons pas oui pourquoi parce qu'on
en a déjà tellement parlé vous êtes ici
ce soir pour un nouvel album du chat qui
s'appelle la loire à chalon ont fait
or nos amis croient qu'il fallait faire
que pour lui il faudrait plutôt ça
combien d'exemplaires vendus de celui-là
ouais j'en sais rien il a il a dit il il
est 4e meilleure vente le 20 mai au
total tous les chats ou de je sais pas
moi de 3 ou 4 millions c'est énorme ça
comment ça commence à devenir cool non
mais le dessinateur
alors c'est très drôle il ya rien a dire
il ya par exemple j'ai cité quelques
trucs mais tout est drôle de toute façon
non mais c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai
par exemple un proverbe serbe notre
passé et sinistre notre présent est
invivable
heureusement que nous n'avons pas
d'avion le 10 avril c'est horrible c'est
drôle alors vous dites le patrimoine à
son année la femme à sa journée le
silence à 5 minutes c'est très bien fait
moins rire mais ça fait réfléchir à ibm
pour ma mère qui va venir enfin ma mère
noël mamère
la chasse deviendra équitable si on
donnait une chance aux animaux il
suffirait de disposer dans la forêt des
mines antipersonnel un coup c'est un
serbe qui saute un goût c'est un
chasseur
alors tout ça vous savez que nous aurons
une femme afghane est géré doute cet
instant pour des raisons que
allez nous exposer sans doute oui est-ce
que vous lui répéterez cette phrase que
dans votre dernier album les femmes
afghanes
au moins elles ne sont pas emmerdé par
les moustiques et c'est la personne ne
l'utilisé que oui mais j'ai jeté un coup
d'oeil c'est un communiqué de l'agent
steinmann j'avais fait c'est évidemment
vous savez il ya pour un dessinateur il
ya des grands des grands stéréotypes de
grands mythes il ya la vénus de milo
qu'on est retraité à toutes les sauces
et la femme afghane martyrisé et la
soeur opprimés dans ce costume
terrifiant évidemment être une
inspiration formidable pour le
dessinateur j'avais aussi un jour faire
un dessin je crois que j'avais publié en
suisse où je disais on voyait deux
femmes afghanes au fond et le chat
disaient les princesses caroline et
stéphanie de kaboul se font moins
emmerdé par les paparazzi ganis temps
vous avez écrit un truc dans un album
précédent qui s'est vérifié si on
mettait du mercurochrome dans les bombes
sa soignerait les premiers blessés
aujourd'hui on voit les américains qui
balance un coup des bombes un coût des
vivres donc j'avais fait ce dessin alors
des bombardements des frappes
chirurgicales en ex yougoslavie
ouais évidemment c'est tristement
d'actualité quand même bien sûr alors il
y en a une pour elizabeth teissier je
parie que mon horoscope n'avait pas
prédit que je ne lirai pas cette semaine
je vais tout de même vérifier c'est déjà
la deuxième puissance et un beau début
là je sens
au même titre et des bulgares et j'avais
fait scier les messieurs oui très très
chaud ce soir bien alors le premier
dessin xavier fit est beaucoup moins
drôle vous aviez 15 ans était dans une
revue pharmaceutique faut dire c'est un
type qui n'avait qu'un bras équipées
chez l'autre mais tel saint dizier qui
avec en braille et d'upi pêcher au bord
d'une rivière il sort de ton truc qui
croient que c'est un poisson et c'est un
autre bras mais j'étais fasciné par les
dessinateurs de de hara kiri faut dire
qu'un vainqueur et les caricaturistes et
ça y est vous avez découvert à acquérir
avant walt disney donc c'est normal vous
étiez très influencée j'ai un petit
bonbon qu'est ce qu'il a fait je crois
que c'était pour moi il a mangé un petit
bonbon
il a sorti un petit peu chez moi ma mère
ma mère m'a toujours dit fais attention
et surtout offre un bon bol est assurée
par john sur mes gardes que ces petits
bonbons c'est quoi moi je veux bien un
petit moment mais je la casse on voit la
bienvenue alors là aussi j'ai mon petit
bond beaucoup d'amis dans la prochaine
et l'on mette j'ai pris un petit chewing
gum symbole de la poche
non non non ces meetings d'accord non si
tu lui fais les poches avant non c'est
pas mais n'attend qu'un jour cela même
en votre chien il s'appelle kim le chien
oui oui le vrai chien à la maison
oui oui il s'appelle qui s'équipent pas
ce que vous dites c'est on s'en servira
plus tard kilim kilims est le nom de
cette habitude est bien sûr mais par
exemple quand il est piquant idées dans
le jardin on à envier à la campagne il
ya des gens qui passent dans la rue il
va il aboie il est gentil mais il aboie
et alors on appelle et on crie kelly
kelly les gens entendent killing tu veux
huit mois et il est vrai que vous passez
acheter les vous rapporte autant de
conquêtes que gérard miller voilà alors
là c'est plutôt des conquêtes négative
parce qu'alors je ramène à des gens
ordinaires
tombeur vous rigolez sont plus doux avec
thierry chaque fois que gérard miller
oscars
10 heures
est ce que vous avez
jusqu'à ce que chaque fois on arrive
mais il attrape ce qu'il veut gérard
miller gérard muller on l'appelle la
mitraillette du paf c'est vous alors je
vais fêter le 10 décembre le 25 ans
d'amour avec ma femme un mari exemplaire
vis des fidèles le ton fidèle à jauger à
chacun de mes passages télé ces seuils
de la reconquérir
ouais davantage et pourtant
charaf est bien bon alors mais ses
recettes tout à fait se faire dans les
liens sacrés du mariage mais ensuite
appellation bonne femme depuis toujours
elle est toujours riche a même vu le bon
soir bien alors on va passer à des
choses plus sérieuses a review on ne
bouge pas valentine galles
[Musique]
vous avez bougé oui oui j'ai vu mon
chien bon j'ai pas réalisé ouais mais
fort dont vous avez les petits martinez
tout à l'heure ils sont destinés à talia
année je les cherche
[Applaudissements]
et petit martin et à la fin bien vous
êtes prêts je peux bouger là à me brière
vous pensez à quoi en ce moment une
chatte comment il sait
franchement que je ne dois pas oublier
que d'annoncer l'émission de vivement
dimanche prochain de demain avec bernard
henri lévy ah oui c'est dramatique on
l'a on me l'avait demandé avant de venir
et je me dis quand je vais pouvoir le
classer et c'est fait moi c'est bien
quand c'est un moyen non ses compos
billet bien quand vous vous regardez
dans le miroir le matin vous dites quoi
trop tard pour la moumoute je me dis
donc je me dis qu'elle
quelle chance il à ce miroir pouvoir
refléter une image aussi sympathique
vous auriez aimé ressembler un clic ans
vous étiez petit orlando petit moi j'ai
essayé mais moi les bronches isama
dessus et les cheveux quand vous auriez
aimé ressembler à quelqu'un vous étiez
petit petit j'aurais voulu être zorro ou
d'artagnan mais me connaissant j'aurais
mis le costume de d'artagnan pour aller
faire euros ouais et le sergent garcia
envers la condition est pas m'arriver
non
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois début septembre pour une histoire
tout à fait privé mais voilà monfils qui
a 18 ans et demi parts et le papa et en
angleterre pour un an pour étudier la
musique et l'anglais et le moment de la
séparation ça a été très émouvant on
était tous en armes étaient les tours
non le 2 septembre je pleurais pas
encore pour les tours
bah ce sens simon n'a pas ce sens de la
prévision d'elisabeth tessier dit depuis
longtemps à l'avancé si la cia vous avez
écouté
si votre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi j'achèterai plutôt dans
le temps une caméra vidéo pour filmer
mes enfants petit parce que j'ai pas de
documents et ils ont horriblement changé
ah oui oui oui mais non je dirais
terriblement sur magnifique mais ils ont
sauvé réaliste et les taureaux
s'attendre à autre chose c'est vrai je
me le dit souvent encore là tout à
l'heure la douche a dit les tours ont
vraiment un
yann l'animal à elle est pragmatique et
rallier à lui permet d'être un peu comme
les chats des grosses couilles grosses
couilles votre chat oui non mais vous le
savez ça mais vous savez pourquoi
maintenant un dessinateur
ouais qu'est ce qui fait quand il doit
quand il doit dessiner quelque chose
d'humain par exemple on regarde ça m'a
aidé
ce qui vous a fait le plus mal
retourne dans ton pays ah oui et on m'a
dit ça à bruxelles je n'ai pas su où
aller la dernière chose que vous faites
avant de vous coucher
non non alors avant de me coucher je
reste quelques minutes debout ou assis
avant pour quoi faire
c'est vraiment le taureau ça c'est ton
droit à la fois t'as pas de +25
alternative avant de se coucher tu es ou
debout à 6 1
son double
la dernière personne que vous ayez envie
de tuer
c'est le type moi c'est les gens vous
savez les gens qui vous tiennent pas la
porte ouverte quand vous les suivez
ouais ce sont les gens qui haïssent et
laird en bagnole quand vous voulez
traverser voici un psychopathe quoi en
fait ce sont les tuer tout le monde en
fait tu as tu vu lui qu'est ce que vous
avez déjà pensé au suicide
oui quand mon premier livre s'achève sur
un dessin du chat qui dit si le type qui
me dessine meurt un jour je me suicide
je suis là si on veut se suicider c'est
mieux de le faire le matin plutôt que le
soir ça fait une journée de boulot en
moins
comment vous vivez avec le chat c'est à
dire vous vous dites il ya des lucas
yann charge imaginez vous vous dites ça
c'est pour le chat le chat penserait ça
ou vous êtes le chat non pas du tout tu
sens très bon orlando la santé mauvais
est-ce que vous avez menti pendant cette
interview là où oui une fois
ah bon quand je vous dis oui une fois
que j'ai menti beaucoup plus souvent
philippiques la sphère le chat le
meilleur album
c'est aux éditions casterman
mais c'est aussi bien que d'habitude
et maintenant celle existant et la wii
que j'avais plus un enfant n'aurait
je ne me serai bien sûr
mickey minnie mickey premier ministe
voici noël mamère
mamère député maire de bègles et
candidat des verts à l'élection
présidentielle le meilleur candidat pour
les verts mais c'est pas un propos de
circonstance il ya longtemps que je les
dis je pense que vous auriez fait un bon
ministre
je remercie je vais tout vous vexer mais
moi j'aurais mis ma mère comme candidat
pour les présidentielles
c'est quand même plus médiatique du
savoir en plus sympa j'ai pas dit ça
mais mais bon je vous avais lu ministre
non je sais pas peut-être oui voilà ça
n'est pas volée circonstances en face
alain lipietz je lui avais dit qu'à mon
avis n'était pas un bon candidat que
vous auriez fait un meilleur candidat et
je suis très intéressé pour être chez
les verts c'est obligé d'avoir les
moustaches on peut s'en passer
est-ce que c'est complètement sûr où il
peut y avoir encore des coups de théâtre
par rapport à votre candidature
la question est intéressante mais je
crois qu'effectivement nous avons déjà
tellement subi de d'avatar que si nous
ne voulons pas réellement couler comme
le radeau de la méduse
il vaut mieux qu'on s'arrête non je ne
sais pas se penser à votre thème là
votre soleil qui est un
et je réfléchis et donc quand vous savez
étant le premier toute façon mais à 4 5
degrés est là en ce moment il ya eu ras
nus ce qui est quand même conquis pitié
[Applaudissements]
je m'excuse série attend c'est je pense
la même chose s'amuse
j'ai appris quand on a des ressources
bon tout ça c'est pas vrai en plus c'est
un animal politique
regardez pour vers ego fois il faut pas
faire comme lui mais j'espère que lui
aussi il était de 24 heures du mans les
exemples c'est encourageant bizarre on a
envie dès aujourd'hui en tous les cas le
feuilleton s'est bien terminée moi je
suis ravie vous l'avez vu et puis en
plus même pour vous parce que alain
lipietz il était quoi 2 3% et vous vous
êtes déjà entre 6 et 8 quoi oui c'est ce
que disent les sondages aujourd'hui don
du genre moi c'est qu'à 5 % et
remboursait c'est vrai oui mais je pense
que les verts mérite de figurer dans une
bonne place aux élections
présidentielles justement on va voir
tout ce que noël mamère une fois qu'il
sera président va apporter aux français
quand tu es
jeumont
est-ce que tu va nous apporter noël
quand tu vas descendre du ciel alors
est-ce que déjà on va sortir du
nucléaire oui oui depuis hier il ya
d'autres pays il faut quand même pas
considérer que la france est un pays qui
seraient isolés du reste du monde ou du
reste de l'europe
philippe geluck les belges les belges
ils sont en train de sortir du nucléaire
ils ont décidé de le faire sur 25 ans à
waimes les allemands je veux pas faire
dans le dans le catastrophisme mais en
fait il ya des journaux très sérieux qui
ont fait des scénarios depuis le 11
septembre puisque maintenant tout est
possible et qui montre que par exemple
l' usine de la qui gardent précieusement
dans des dans des piscines du plutonium
qui est très dangereux si un bruit je le
dis aussi un boeing tombé sur la safra
peu près 60 cette fois le césium qui est
le produit le plus dangereux le produit
radioactif le plus dangereux qu a lâché
tchernobyl non c'est bon ça j'en profite
comme la télé pour dire dans cette piste
il faut mettre le bonnet il a pleinement
il faut se couvrir
nous pensons les verts qu'il faudra une
génération pour sortir du nucléaire
entre temps il ya un certain nombre de
choses à faire comme par exemple
rechercher par exemple transporter les
camions principalement sur des trames la
langue ne plus faire voler concorde
il est content parce que ça dépend
et oui ça dépense beaucoup d'énergie
c'est complètement contraire aux accords
de kyoto qu'on a signés et sa dépense
beaucoup d'énergie pour combien de monde
pour commander personnes à quelques
privilégiés
trois mille balles allaient ouvrir vous
dis oui pendant ce temps n'a pas assez
d'argent pour la justice l'indépendance
de la corse est au programme des
tènements pas non non non l'autonomie de
la corse lui comme l'autonomie des
régions comme ça existe par exemple en
espagne
ouais en espagne on peut parler catalan
se sentir espagnol et européen est resté
en même temps la première région en
dynamisme économique et culturel
oui pourquoi pas il ya la france est un
vieux pays pour ça vous êtes allez aller
en sardaigne aller en écosse allait aux
baléares l'afghanistan maintenant pour
vous finalement les américains et
bombarde un pays en ruine
ça sert à rien pour vous c'est seulement
de la vengeance et c'est la loi du
talion plus qu'autre chose la question
qu'on peut se poser maintenant qu'on est
dans votre émission ça fait à peu près
cinq semaines que les bombardements ont
commencé les talibans sont toujours là
ben laden nargue l'ensemble du monde et
des valeurs universelles qu'on essaie de
défendre pas simplement un accident est
compris dans certains pays arabes
modérés et on s'aperçoit que ça provoque
des colonnes et des colonnes de damnés
de la terre qui ont déjà subi cette
misère psychologique morale physique
depuis l'union soviétique après ça a été
les seigneurs de guerre
et puis après il ya eu les talibans
maintenant il ya les américains d'autre
faut demander aux américains quel est le
but de la guerre est ce que c'est comme
nous le souhaitons tous de tenter
d'éradiquer le terrorisme international
ou est-ce que c'est simplement de virer
les talibans qui nous plaît demain pour
les remplacer par des talibans modérés
qui du coup ne voit qu'une seule main et
pourquoi n'y a aucun juge américain qui
a lancé un mandat d'amener contre ben
laden
c'est ce qu'on dit puisque les
américains nous disent et à juste titre
que ce qui s'est passé contre les twin
towers c'est un crime contre l'humanité
dont il faut le qualifier comme tels
et si on le qualifie comme tel alors il
faut mettre en oeuvre le tribunal pénal
international sauf que les américains
ils n'ont pas ratifié le traité 1 qui
fixe et le tribunal pénal
la mère qui n'ont pas payé leur dette à
l'onu comment peut-on demander une
opération de police internationale la
même manière qu'ils n'ont pas ratifié
l'accord sur l'interdiction du travail
des enfants est d'accord sur les mines
antipersonnel par exemple donc moi je
suis pas anti américains mais je demande
qu'il soit responsable devant la société
internationale alors bon voilà ça c'est
tout le programme des verts pour les
présidentielles le même si vous n'êtes
pas tout seul ben non c'est dommage mais
bon y'a jospin vous dit en parlant de
jose pas au nom du réalisme il ne va pas
assez loin
enfin c'est quelque chose vous savez
bien noël mamère que socialistes ont
toujours très avec le sourire quand même
on peut dire ça oui on peut pas dire que
guy mollet a été un farouche partisan la
force ouvrière exemple un seul parti
communiste a aussi trahi la classe
ouvrière en le remettant l'avenir
radieux et parlez-moi de jose par jospin
il est prisonnier de la cohabitation
d'abord un ce qui à mon avis est une
illusion contre laquelle il faut se
battre parce que les français se disent
finalement ce n'est pas plus mal
il ya un premier ministre de gauche et
puis un président de droite et
finalement ça équilibre m'annonça
équilibre rien et ça freine les freine
les grandes réformes
et puis jospin bbc le premier ministre
d'une gauche qui est principalement
gestionnaire est passé de gauche là qui
m'intéressent
ouais le pen aussi va être dans la
campagne des présidentielles
est-ce que vous très sale démocratique
qui n'arrivent pas à recueillir 500
signatures il les aura ses 500
signatures c'est maigret qu'il ne les
aura pas quand on arrive à faire sens en
se taisant comme c'est son cas
aujourd'hui près de 11 % dans les
sondages
ça veut dire que il y as chez les
français un sentiment de troubles de
peur d'un qui luttent par rapport à
beaucoup de choses
quand vous dites qu'il se tait est-ce
que c'est lui qui s'était hissé les
médias qu'elles font taire non je pense
qu'il a compris parce que c'est un vieux
politicien habile que les événements
sont en train de le servir et que quand
la gauche avec la complicité de la
droite votent une loi sécuritaire qui
nous aurait fait descendre dans la rue
dans les années 80 ce sens prenant aux
jeunes qui font des rave parties en les
criminalisant 1 en faisant croire qu'on
va trouver des terroristes dans les
coffres des bagnoles en stigmatisant les
banlieues en permettant de
pouvoir interpeller des jeunes qui sont
au pied des tours ou par exemple en
permettant à des vigiles qui sont des
polices privées de faire de la fouille
au corps
c'est pas d adrien c'est pas des thierry
ou des noëls qui sont arrêtés c'est saïd
mercialys et des autres si ça c'est pas
bien et c'est la gauche quand elles
marchent sur les terres de la droite n'a
pas tiré les leçons elle perd tout le
temps alors on continue vos concurrents
béroud françois bayrou c'est ta nuit
s'il a battu béroul un an comment il est
un peu abattu l'instant il est mal gérée
précis fondation au colza calcul raté
tous ses sensations plus tôt et alors
d'accord c'est vrai j'ai le lien
pourquoi je dis ça on a invité françois
bo à venir dans cette émission il dit
j'ai peur de venir et moisson
extraordinaire qu'un mec qui veut
diriger la quatrième puissance mondiale
et peur devient chez thierry ardisson
pouvoir non mais je pense de sa
faiblesse surtout je pense qu'il est
dans une situation
l'enjeu une situation difficile d'abord
à droite chirac est quand même puissant
le rpr aussi et donc il va pas lui faire
de cadeaux les idées que défend bayrou
certaines sont tout à fait respectable
quand même ses idées sur l'europe mais
c'est vrai qu'au qu' on est dans un pays
dans lequel le centre n'a jamais
réellement existé ça a toujours été une
force d'appoint il est laminée là alors
madelin qui se rapproche de charles
meyer en ce moment qui revient peut-être
à ses idées d'origine ainsi rac alors la
chirac c'est pas votre copain un contre
jacques chirac sarkozy qu'il engage la
france dans les affaires afghanes sans
avoir consulté l'assemblée nationale n'y
a pas de lui qui fait ça c'est mon
premier ministre jose bat aussi son côté
moi je suis déprimé raison je suis je
crois un représentant du peuple france
il n'y a pas eu très peur j'ai serré la
main de george bush nous sommes des amis
qu'il a à [ __ ] georges boulogne
jacques chirac pour la guerre c'est lui
qui l'amène tout seul bien sûr et donc
il peut plastronner sur le péristyle de
la maison blanche à côté de bouche qui
dit c'est mon ami jacques chirac un cas
à part ça elle le dit j'en vois deux
mille deux mille militaires pour aider
les américains et que fait-on de la
commission des affaires étrangères la
commission de la défense et de ceux qui
sont censés représenter le peuple
français on nous demande même pas notre
avis vous avez raison alors vous trouvez
qu'il va trop souvent trouve que chirac
c'est ça me rappelle une affaire que
j'avais aussi quand j'étais journaliste
il me rappelle les avions renifleurs
schirrhein mérillon unis fleurs donc le
lundi il est écolo le mardi les pour les
ogm
le mercredi il estoit la tolérance zéro
le jeudi 1er prend ses billets en
espèces le vendredi il est militant
d'attac
il est capable d'aller dans les pays
arabes en usant vous savez les droits de
l'homme si la date sable
les procès d'intention on connaît sa
dimension c'est la règle non à rodez on
dit tous des conneries la preuve est
révocable
oui je pense que effectivement ce mot
est devenu à la mode
ouais je suis je suis menacé par le
ridicule je m'aperçois avec un certain
soulagement que ça ne tue pas puisque je
peux vous répondre ce soir mais ce que
je voudrais dire c'est que moi je crois
qu'on peut douter
j'ai douté parce que j'avais peur que le
parti soit tellement divisée que hessam
empêcherait de faire une campagne qui me
permettrait de parler à l'ensemble de la
société et sur le terrain des
convictions je pense que je suis plutôt
irrévocable et que je n'ai pas changé
d'avis et c'est l'essentiel
alors vous dit en parlant de chirac qui
surf sur l'air du temps mais en fait les
français sont moins en moins d'accord
pour l'intervention en afghanistan et
continue à être né en tant que non parce
que si vous avez remarqué ce qu'il a dit
il ya déjà les signes de son changement
avant il dit oui la solution militaire
n'est pas la seule il faut aussi
envisager des solutions politiques alors
il est en train de balancer ce qu'on
appelle des leurs en termes militaires
par exemple conférence internationale
sur l'aide humanitaire
c'est la conception du bien et du mal de
bouche le bia on envoie des cacahuètes
et de la confiture avec les avions ça
c'est un détournement obscène de la
philosophie de l'aide humanitaire
puis apprend balance des bombes parce
que comme ça ils pourront mourir le
ventre plein c'est comme le demande
c'est pas une conférence sur l'aide
humanitaire parce que ça fait longtemps
que le peuple par exemple puisqu'on a
reçu un putschiste dié maintenant drapé
de toutes les vertus
le général musharraf n'est pas content
du pakistan on lui a supprimé sa dette
mais on ne fait pas aux pays d'afrique
où 40% du continent africain vit avec
moins de un dollar par jour
on n'a pas imposé de sanctions pour les
essais nucléaires pratiqués par le
pakistan et on ne l'obligent pas
aujourd'hui à ouvrir ses frontières pour
accueillir ces malheureuses à volants
qui sont coincés qu'ils sont victimes
des dégâts des terreaux de noël on est
d'accord
le plan moral des raisons maintenant je
vais bien que si demain le pakistan
céder ce serait la femme est arrivée au
col à allah c'est la fin des haricots
parce qu'à côté il ya un pays qui
s'appelle il ya une zone qui s'appelle
le cachemire si aussi dangereuse que le
proche orient mais c'est à dire on est
dans une danse d'une société dans un
monde où on marcha à grands pas vers
l'inconnu
ouais alors jospin oui quoi vous
puissiez dire au deuxième tour vous
demanderez qu'on vote pour lui coûter la
question d'abord c'est de savoir si
jospin sera candidat à la présidence un
il n'a pas encore annoncé
- côté je suis candidat des verts les
verts sont dans la gauche donc ce que je
souhaite c'est que l'on fasse gagner la
gauche mais pas n'importe quelle gauche
à une gauche gestionnaire mais la
réalité c'est que gérer ga je veux
combattre la droite oui c'est sûr rozier
même écouter les troisième homme y en a
il ya un champion d'automne paris qui
s'appelle jean pierre chevènement
je trouvais qu'il a complètement
retourné sa veste et que de l'autre côté
avec le horizon c'est ça oui d'ailleurs
jean pierre chevènement et c'est ce qui
est et ce qui est intéressant à analyser
c'est que il apparaît comme un homme
neuf
alors que il a été rédacteur du
programme commun en 1972 qu'il a
appartenu pratiquement à tous les ans
tous les gouvernements de la gauche
depuis 81 et s'il apparaît comme un oeuf
comme un homme neuf ça veut dire que nos
deux locomotives de droite et de gauche
chirac et jospin se répète beaucoup et
qu il yal il ya une volonté ya une
aspiration des français pour entendre
autre chose des candidats aux
présidentielles
il me semble que chirac a une toute
petite avance ici cet antre jospin et
chirac que ça se passe mal à me semble
que voilà mais
oui mais après au deuxième il faudra
bien choisir et noël ne sera pas avec un
témoin cité assure à nu ce qui se
décidera ne fait pas grossir
non
les ouvriers de la boillat son numéro de
portable nom la date de naissance et là
quand c'est un coup qu'elle a bien
est-ce que vous êtes prêts noël on va
faire vous êtes candidat aux
présidentielles
on va faire une interview si j'étais
président on ne bouge pas pendant le
single
[Musique]
noël mamère alors si vous étiez
président est ce que vous auriez un
astrologue auprès de vous non je pense
pas j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
elisabeth tessier mais j'ai les pieds
comme les capricornes barre et ils ont
les pieds bien enraciné dans l'air donc
je crois je joue je crois plutôt
honnêtement c'est de la connerie tout ça
oui enfin pour moi c'est des gens qui y
croient tant mieux ou tant pis pour eux
s'ils sont rassurés si ça leur fait des
minerais comme françois mitterrand une
astronome non franchement non c'est
difficile parce que les consultations
non quand on pense que des gens comme
einstein ou you may ont cru je veux dire
je suis intéressé
non ils feraient pas lorsque je
travaille pas pour rire je l'embrassais
non merkel m brasse dans ces cas là
einstein nadine travel show sur la
grille il a dit deux choses sont
infinies l'univers et la connerie
humaine et encore pour l'univers je suis
pas tout à fait ça bien ont continué
d'appliquer beaucoup j'ai senti un peu
oublié ces temps troublés là je suis je
suis quoi tu
bientôt tu seras couette et entier et
ensuite elle sera cuite
noël mamère qu'elle s'agit sagittaire du
lait contaminé lui tendant l'uranus mais
en même temps c'est pas les années
qu'est ce qu'un joueur ambitieux review
avait visé monica lewinsky pourquoi pas
les séries la grande différence si ça
c'est bien
c'est qu'en france on est les normes et
parce que la grande différence bah oui
chers amis c'est que en france on jure
sur la constitution et non pas sur la
bible il vaut mieux rester un état laïc
ça donne pas des affaires comme l'a fait
remarquer lewinsky d'accord mais ça veut
quand même dire que vous êtes un grand
coup
vous tournez à dire que vous croyez pas
les mêmes efforts en monica lewinsky que
c'est que les demandes on passe alors la
grave problème le dalaï lama est de
passage à paris
je le reçois évidemment mais si vous le
recevez la chine annuler une commande de
80 airbus wiba la chine pour l'instant
savez je me suis beaucoup battu et je
continuerai de le faire contre ces
géronte mafieux qui dirige aujourd'hui
la chine qui ont mis des millions de
français alex ma mère et vous savez que
comme par exemple vous achetez à vos
enfants des jouets made in china ou
quand vous allez dans un magasin de
bricolage pour acheter des objets made
in china la plupart sont fabriqués dans
ce qu'on appelle des laogaï c'est à dire
l'équivalent de l'école a fermé les gens
et qui travaille pour rien et on vient
d'accepter que la chine rentrer à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce vous
êtes série debout devant comme ça mais
devant un vrai stepan tungstène vélo
fidel castro vient de mourir bon bah
c'est une crapule de moins sur la terre
merci vous avez pas aux obsèques a
certainement pas j'ai été interdit de
séjour à cuba parce que je voulais faire
des reportages clandestins à jouer ça
des reportages sur les banques
s'ils voulaient viser présent c'est vrai
soyez rassurés je suis tricorps avec
tous les dictateurs dans la terre
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi
elle serait noël mamère votre conseiller
spirituel dieu un êtes croyants oui si
vous étiez président la république
que feriez-vous de dominique vallet
premier ministre un premier mis à bas
oui c'est vrai que la voie la bassée
règle elle a un boulot très bien cette
fille c'est vrai taureau scorpions et
[Applaudissements]
noël nous allons reparler de
l'afghanistan puisque nous recevons
maintenant latif hauteur de visage volet
avoir 20 ans à kaboul
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
latifa bonsoir je suis à chevy bonsoir
vous êtes traduire oui oui vous êtes la
présidente de l'association afghanistan
libre et je dois dire que noël mamère
est un des seuls hommes politiques en
france à avoir été présent à la
manifestation en faveur des femmes
afghanes le 29 septembre dernier
voilà alors donc latifa publie chez anne
carrière
un livre qui s'appelle visage volet
avoir 20 ans à kaboul qui raconte la vie
avant et après le pouvoir des talibans
interview vérité
on
[Musique]
latifa vous êtes né dans une famille
aisée de kaboul
votre mère était gynécologue votre père
était dans l'import export et vous est
la dernière de cinq enfants
vous êtes né en 1981 ce qui veut dire
que vous n'avez connu que la guerre
alors dit à force de vivre dans la
guerre nous étions devenus indifférents
à la tragédie de notre pays nous étions
anesthésiés au point de ne pas voir
arriver
l'ultime menace les talibans c'est à
dire que derrière cette guerre il y
avait quelque chose d'encore plus graves
qui arrivait alors jusqu'à l'âge de
saison et malgré le fait que votre pays
soit dans la guerre vous avez une vie
assez insouciante
d'une certaine façon qu'ils mangent
jusqu'à l'âge de ces enjeux j'avais une
adolescence insouciante
j'ai été à quelques mois de passer mon
bac à l'orias j'avais des amis garçons
ou filles et surtout j'étais mal je
m'étais inscrite à la faculté de
journalisme pour devenir journaliste oui
c'est vrai qu'avant l'arrivée des
talibans vous participiez des rencontres
sportives des rencontres culturelles
vous parlez de mode avec vos amis vous
alliez au cinéma vous vouliez devenir
journaliste effectivement ça fait partie
de ce que faisait partie de ma vie avant
mes 16 ans et en parlait de mode avec
les amis surtout on écoutait beaucoup de
musique la musique c'était très
important pour nous voilà et pendant ce
temps là avec l'aide des américains avec
l'aide des usa le pakistan venait en
aide à la mise en place des talibans
dassault 7 rond d'orléans voiler la face
on a dit que maradona zidane avant l
arrivée des talibans je m'intéressais
pas beaucoup à la politique je dois le
dire ça me dépasse un petit peu je
m'intéressais pas mais voir ces
étrangers dans mon pays ça m'a permis de
m'intéresser un peu plus à la
géopolitique et de voir ces étrangers
sur notre sol est voir d'où il venait et
ça ça fait encore plus mal effectivement
alors le 27 septembre 1996 les talibans
entre dans le câble houle
les écoles sont fermées les femmes sont
humiliés insultés enfermé est obligé de
porter ce que vous portez ce soir c'est
à dire le tchadri sharks au balcon
blasik est à charlesbourg cheikh hassan
daoud jeune soldat guina koné 27
septembre c'est vrai que c'était le jour
qu'il a basculé l'avis de toutes les
femmes un caveau toutes les jeunes
filles et cette ville est devenue une
ville en deuil
du jour au lendemain et moi j'étais plus
là latifa de la veille j'ai changé un
jour effectivement comme toutes les
jeunes filles 27 septembre 96 alors ces
talibans sont pas tous afghans ni même
tous patchoune il ya des pakistanais il
ya des arabes
ils ont une chose en commun c'est d'être
barbu et d'avoir une barbe qui doit
mesurer la longueur de la main
avec le ghana au togo à staline a tiré
sur tout ce qu' ils ont aussi c'est un
regard atroce c'est affreux qui vous
brisent qui vous glacent le sang seul
instant il suffit de croiser son regard
et je peux vous dire que vous l'oubliez
plus jamais la première chose qui vous
étonne vraiment c'est que les talibans
exhibe la dépouille de l'ex président
najib ou là qui a été lynché avant
d'être pendu et vous le voyez avec des
cigarettes enfoncé dans la bouche et des
billets qui dépasse de ses poches et
pour vous c'est un spectacle ignoble
c'était encore plus ignoble de voir ça
et surtout la sauvagerie des aliments
puisque docteur n'est du goût là
qu'était le président était un pachtoune
et qu'il pensait qu'avec les talibans
ils allaient tous trouvé un allié et le
voir pendu dès le premier jour ça nous a
montré à quel point ils sont capables du
pire c'était beau
et puis viennent les consignes des
talibans les décrets respecter
l'avalanche des interdits les filles et
les femmes n'ont plus le droit de
travailler à l'extérieur les lois
commencé à venir les unes après les
autres
pas seulement pour les femmes mais aussi
pour les hommes parce que le sort des
hommes étaient payés pas mieux non plus
parce que toute l'administration étaient
fermées donc les hommes non plus n'avait
pas le droit de travailler puisque
aucune administration nous fonctionner à
part le ministère de la promotion de la
vertu et utilise alors
les femmes ne peuvent plus sortir sans
être revêtue du tchad riz et sans être
accompagnées d'un homme charles rocha
march est alors imaginer le sort de
toutes ces veuves qui depuis 18 années
de guerre parce qu'avant les talibans y
avait dix huit années de guerre qui
n'avaient pas d'homme et qui n'avait pas
de mari ou pas de frère avait perdu
imaginer le sort de ces femmes à quel
point elle se faisait humilier et toutes
ces femmes qui pour exister dans la rue
simple pour faire une simple course a
besoin d'une présence masculine
il y en avait pas dans les familles qu'à
boudinés pas dans toutes les familles
présence masculine alors fini le
maquillage fini le rouge à lèvres fini
le vernis à ongles et si on porte du
vernis à ongles on peut avoir les doigts
coupés
c'était un dd des histoires rapportées
par une de mes amies proches j'ai rêvé
vu justement les doigts coupés de cette
femme et moi je vous raconte l'anecdote
delà de cette femme avec ses chaussures
blanches mais la première fois que je
suis sorti dans la rue et qui ce qui m'a
décidé de ne plus sortir dans la partir
de ce jour là c'était de rencontrer
cette femme dans la rue qui se faisait
attraper par ce qu'il faut et rempli de
plomb au pied parce qu'elle portait des
chaussures blanches qui était la même
couleur que la couleur des drapeaux les
talibans et qu'il fallait que ça
devienne rouge comme ça avec la couleur
de sens où aucun médecin homme ne doit
toucher le corps d'une femme et comme
les femmes ne peuvent plus travailler
elles ne sont plus soignés donc elle
meurt médecins ne pouvaient toucher les
femmes et moi même c'est injuste
exemple pour me faire soigner jésuite
jesús quitté kaboul pour partir à
peshawar au pakistan pour me faire
soigner parce que le médecin n'avait pas
le droit de me toucher ou nous soigner
interdit d'écouter de la musique
interdit de faire des photos musiques du
sud où la voilà la musique était
interdite dès le début ce qui nous a le
plus touché nous les jeunes parce que ça
faisait partie de notre vie quotidienne
mais malgré ça on avait quand même notre
résistance était d'écouter de la musique
clandestine et donc d'avoir des
cassettes et des à l'intérieur de la
maison la peur au ventre en écouter
quand même la musique alors les non
musulmans sont obligés de revêtir des
vêtements jaune ce qui rappelle ici de
bons souvenirs interdit de vendre des
sous vêtements féminins
oui ces objets étaient ainsi derek comme
un des objets profane est alors le plus
étonnant pourquoi interdit de sifflets
et de posséder des bouilloires sifflante
rappelé ça rappelait l'allèle les sons
musicaux et sarah paix pour eux c'est
hélas la voie du satin interdit de
posséder des chiens ou des oiseaux vous
êtes obligé de dire adieu à votre chien
bingo non seulement j en ai dû se
séparer de nos animaux mais sachez que
le sort de beaucoup d'entre nous étaient
bien pires que ces animaux dont on était
obligé de se séparer
voilà et puis à le tchadri donc avant
les talibans quand vous voyez des femmes
revêtues du tchadri vous les ateliers
les les bouteilles vous les ateliers les
choux fleurs à l'envers vous appeliez
les sacs à provisions
se moquer de ces femmes c'est pauvre
femme avec mes amis pas seulement moi
mais mes amis jamais on était loin de se
douter qu'un jour on serait nous mêmes
des choux fleurs
alors au début vous restez chez vous et
puis voulait pas sortir vêtus du tchad
riz à kaboul
et puis un jour devant l'insistance
d'une amie vous essayez et vous dit ce
n'est pas un vêtement c'est une prison
tout seul quand je discutais toutes ces
jeunes filles beaucoup de jeunes filles
pas les femmes nous agit mais surtout
les jeunes filles
il faut vraiment qu'on attend d'une
excuse pour se faire soigner ou une
vraie excuse pour sortir de la maison
parce qu'on se dit sortir d'une prison
dans une autre au moins dans la nôtre
l'intérieur on n'est pas obligé de venir
nous frappe et humilié alors qu'avec
notre prison le tchadri on n'est pas
l'abri de l'humiliation quatre mois donc
après l'arrivée des talibans vous sortez
enfin et vous dites pourtant ce qui
prouve l'état d'esprit vous dites si mon
futur mari me demandait de porter un
foulard ou un tchador hors de la maison
j'accepterai son problème est une maman
de m'embaucher mais la passion d'airasia
le tchador quand je faisais ma prière
dans mon coin
donc effectivement je suis une musulmane
croyante pratiquante
oui nous devons partager le même point
de vue et savoir pourquoi je le porte
et pour rien au monde je perdrais aucune
autre de mes libertés
et puis elle est violent un jour 3 jeune
fille arrive chez vous pour être soigné
par votre mère d'une façon clandestine
et vous découvrez à ce moment là
qu'elles ont été victimes non seulement
de viols et de mutilations et dégagerait
à tabou de queiroz a dit gay majorité du
sénat vous donne à chaque but
sager quasi est nommé connaître aux
hommes et à jeanne effectivement qu'on
était capable qu'on pouvait un être
humain ne pouvait être capable de
traiter avec autant de violence et de
haine une femme c'est quelque chose je
vous assure que tu n'imagines ap tant
qu'on ne voit pas être saisis on peut
pas imaginer qu'un homme peut faire
autant de mal à gratuitement pendant ce
temps le ministre de la santé des
talibans est reçu à paris dans le pays
des droits de l'homme
et quand vous apprenez ça quelle est
votre réaction comment tu en as marre
aux à gauche et à la fraude et au bout d
un mois djibouti comores a banni la
gauche mais la radio clandestine à cette
époque là donc c'était notre seule
occupation aussi d'écouter cette radio
de chercher les informations
je vous raconte pas la tristesse des
gens à kaboul de voir cette propagande
faite par les talibans de voir ce
représentant tellement qu'ils étaient
reçus dans un pays européen
qui plus est le pays de la démocratie
des droits de l'homme je peux vous dire
qu'ils ont fait de la propagande pour
nous dire qu'ils ont été reconnus ici et
là vous quitter l'afghanistan avec votre
père votre mère et une amie une fatwa
est lancé contre vous parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez peur de cette
fatwa un an et qui embrument encore
icade à bout de mâchoire d'audabram
comme un vrai mental j'ai moins peur
pour moi pour moi plus j'ai plus peur
pour toutes ces femmes qui m'ont choisie
pour venir porter leur message ici et
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui la balle est
donc j'ai aucune nouvelle je sais pas ce
qu'elle devienne c'est pour elle que
j'ai plus peur parce que c'est elle qui
sont en danger
latifa aujourd'hui des gens en france
vous regardent des gens à l'étranger
vous regarde dans beaucoup de pays du
monde
qu'avez vous à dire aux gens qui vous
regardent
non mais un barème amont mais johnny ni
à wall membres à son examen avant d'être
promu en affichant dès lors dire que
jusqu'à jusqu'à quand ce silence cette
indifférence contre la faim de marianne
qui aujourd'hui souffrent la batterie ou
non sa place et a marqué trop de temps à
sa famille la famille organes c'est une
femme aussi comme n'importe quelle femme
dans le monde si un jour ce sort vous
touche
ça m'étonnerait que vous acceptiez ce
sort ligh je pense que vous serez bien
content deux camps soient toutes les
femmes dans le monde viennent vous vient
de vous aider ça fait longtemps ça fait
trop longtemps aujourd'hui l'afghanistan
et les afghans surtout les aveux d'un
besoin compenser les blessures royaume
si quelqu'un vous poser des questions à
latifa noël c'est isabelle philippe
rolland dottikon c'est absolument
terrifiant et moi je t'ai on ne peut que
vous exprimer notre respect et notre
solidarité vous demandez ce que nous
pouvons faire nous citoyens pour vous
pour vous aider si besoin d'éducation
c'est la base même de ce dont nous
voulons aujourd'hui en afghanistan
aidez nous à voir la paix dans notre
pays pour qu'on puisse reconstruire déjà
aujourd'hui vous avez nous avons
désormais très bien décédé depuis des
années déjà vous pouvez aider ces zones
là c'est aussi un combat comme un autre
jour de poser des questions à latifa oui
d'abord je ne comprends pas comment vous
avez pu en arriver là c'est une question
cruel peut-être mais la femme toujours
eu au sein de la société
un pouvoir même si c'était un pouvoir
cacher il ya un pouvoir sur les sur les
maris pouvoir sur les frères ya un
pouvoir sur les ficelles donne la vie
donc allez quand même l'intermédiaire
absolument indispensable d'une société
comment se peut-il que c'est un tel
pouvoir qui est qui et lanteri nation de
la lutte dans l'essex au dans le sens le
plus barbare puisse être s'être
installée voilà ma question je comprends
pas je ne comprends pas je m'envoie dit
la meute à la jungle avec andrew jarrett
aliments sont arrivés au pouvoir en
afghanistan il y avait déjà dix huit
années de guerre derrière ce peuple donc
il y avait déjà dix huit années de
guerre derrière ce peuple donc le peuple
était détruit avec l'invasion soviétique
et quand ils sont arrivés il y avait
déjà un peuple détruits et les talibans
pour la plupart sont des jeunes prélever
tout tout petit et qui sont élevés dans
des madrassas en dehors de tout tout
amour maternel au nord de toute présence
et qui ne savent absolument pas ce que
vous dire l'amour et la chaleur d'une
famille donc forcément c'est là où on
fabrique sont pas des talibans ne se
sont pas révoltés contre cet état de
fait
parce qu'en même sans leurs femmes et
ils les ont déshabillées femmes les
hommes et les femmes se révoltent tous
les jours contre les talibans et ne
serait-ce qu' on est quand même
aujourd'hui au bout de cinq semaines une
armée comme l'armée américaine n'arrive
pas à toucher des talibans nous ça fait
sept ans qu'on se bat contre les
talibans
et contre le terrorisme et nous avons
quand même des zones libres où il ya 5
millions de personnes qui habitent
on continue à construire des écoles des
hôpitaux et à donner du travail aux
femmes et ça veut bien dire qu'on a
réussi là où aujourd'hui les plus grande
armée du monde échoue des hommes
talibans vis-à-vis des femmes
parce que s'ils détruisent toutes les
femmes comment ils vont c'est pourquoi
et comment ils vont continuer à se
lasser ceux ci s'étaient pas c'est pas
du tout c'est une machination de l'état
l'immense et les pakistanais aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont reçus par le quai d'orsay ce
sont aussi les arabes l'arabie saoudite
et les émirats puisque c'est les trois
pays qui reconnaissent le régime des
talibans où ils ont leurs ambassades
aujourd'hui et le but c'est pas de
prendre le laissez pas de progrès ou
quoi que ce soit le but c'est de
reprendre le territoire afghan
donc le meilleur façon de détruire une
nation c'est détruire sa femme donc par
la destruction de la femme afghane ont
détruit la nation afghane et on al
territoire libre d'afghanistan qui est
quand même l'objet de convoitises depuis
des centaines et des milliers ne sais
pas dernière question
les français se demandent ce qu'il faut
faire il se demande s'il faut soutenir
les américains ils se demandent s'il ya
d'autres moyens d'action
vous qui êtes afghane et qui militait
pour un afghanistan libre et
démocratique que nous conseillez-vous
c'est très simple il faut déjà une
pression il faut arrêter de 2,2 jouer
avec les gens en recevant celui dont les
avants demande aujourd'hui qu'il soit
devant le tribunal international c'est
le pakistan et le président un mouchard
f aujourd'hui les reçus comme un de nos
meilleurs amis comme c'était le cas il
ya quelques mois pour les talibans donc
ça c'est insupportable pour les avants
ça peut pas passer alors que les afghans
en afghanistan la semaine dernière me
demander tu vas faire quelque chose
là-bas pour leur dire qu'il faut mettre
le pakistan devant le tribunal
international
aujourd'hui il est ici au quai d'orsay
donc je me sens un peu faible et de
l'autre côté il ya des il faut faire de
l'humanitaire dans les zones où les gens
sont en train de mourir avec le froid
qui approche dans les zones où souvent
c'est fait c'est pas très facile d'accès
pour les ong donc il faut y aller mais
surtout il faut aider les zones libres
dans les projets de développement
il faut faire en sorte que ces gens
continuent dans leur élan d'espoir et
qui continuent à être opérationnel le
jour où le pays libre ces femmes
continuent à être opérationnel au jour
ce pays est libre
je suis allé dans un camp de réfugiés
une femme qui me regarde dans les yeux
me dit j'ai perdu mon mari mon frère
mais tu pourras faire quelque chose pour
la petite pour qu'elles aillent à
l'école donc ça veut dire qu'elle elle
continue à croire louis si on n'a pas le
droit de les abonnés il faut soutenir
les américains alors puisqu'ils sont
blur leur but c'est de ces sacs se pose
la question pose la question puisque
leur but c'est de détruire les talibans
alors faut-il soutenir les américains
quelle est l'opinion d'une afghane je
pense que le pignon d'une afghane et des
avancées que l'europe puisse enfin
trouver une identité et que ne suivent
pas les américains aveuglément etc les
avants ils attendent beaucoup plus des
européens et des français aujourd'hui
depuis toujours un à dix les français
ont idéalisé massoud et tout le monde
pense que la france a beaucoup aidés
massoud ce qui est pas ce qui n'est pas
le cas ce qui est pas vrai comme vous
avez très bien dit monsieur mamère dans
un article que trois mois après sa
réception ici rien n'avait bougé pour
l'alliance
donc on l'a dit pendant des années a été
victime de notre grand amour avec la
france mais c'est pas pour autant que la
france nous a aidés merci
[Applaudissements]
et
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
eh ben dis donc voilà donc c'était le
témoignage de latifa et c'est un petit
peu finalement grâce à la télévision
comme si pendant la guerre on avait vu
des gens qui seraient sortis d'un camp
de concentration pour venir témoigner la
télévision donc là on peut pas dire
qu'on savait pas puisque on sait voilà
c'est que la grande différence avec ce
qui s'est passé entre 1942 et 1945 voilà
quelques emails à suivre pour continuer
la petite fred qui m'envoie un email
pour stéphane rien ne m'empêchera de thé
mais les barreaux et les murs de la
prison ne sont pas aussi solides que mon
amour l'amour c'est pour le meilleur et
pour le pire
on a commencé par le pire viendra
bientôt le meilleur je t'aime beaucoup
du mail pour savoir qui est l'ange blond
qu'on voit la fin de l'émission qui
vient prendre mes fiches de la fin
d'émission
est ce qu'elle peut venir agatha
inséparables en deux ans et parlant de
agathe et revient
agatha
sinon petit ange blond est bouclée c'est
agatha maintenant vous savez qui c'est
un email de mehdi de lyon qui dit j'ai
perdu un bout de shit sur votre plateau
l'avez vous retrouver non pas du tout et
on repasse à michaël blanc donc déjà 45
mille huit cent cinquante francs étaient
envoyés au comité de soutien et je
répète que ce 7 d'or et ce hot d'or sont
à vendre et que l'argent ira donc pour
soutenir michaël blanc
[Musique]
je reçois maintenant jean louis aubert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamais
jean louis aubert est la même
et voilà jean louis aubert ma mère
elizabeth teissier voilà alors jean
louis aubert bas inutile de trois hôtels
pour moi d'arriver après j'arrive et le
coeur léger j'arrivais pour faire voilà
et non pas du tout et donc je trouve
maintenant on sait rien n'est comme
avant un peu moins jean louis aubert
fondateur et songwriter du plus grand
groupe français de rock n roll téléphone
et puis après le split une carrière solo
plus ou moins solo avec certains autres
membres du groupe
musique maestro
[Applaudissements]
point
[Musique]
pas mal
et
un jour s'est levé sur une étrange idée
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai voté
m
pas sûr
et
[Musique]
le porter
le seul combat
jamais
m
je te
[Musique]
mais voilà jean louis aubert
très bon sens bien quand même loin dit
sont bonnes c'est patricia la voyante
c'est plutôt lui la bombe humaine après
new york avec toi jeu et après je rêvais
d'un autre monde
et oui je rêvais d'un autre monde
aujourd'hui jean louis aubert sort un
nouvel album qui s'appelle comme un
accord sur comment on fait jean louis
c'est la tradition dans cette émission
attention
et si même un président de la république
le fader j'ai fait et vous l'avez fait
j'ai donné voilà est le premier single
donc s'appelle alter ego l'entend
beaucoup à la radio en ce moment
tu es
[Musique]
t
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà alter ego jean louis aubert nouvel
album nouveau single vous avez fait un
concert le 22 octobre à l'elysée
montmartre un duo avec axel bauer vous
avez joué un autre monde et est un des
grands succès d'axel bauer s'appelle
éteint la lumière et axel bauer il était
au concert des who
en 69 au théâtre des champs elysées
était tous vous dites tous les gens qui
étaient à ce concert sont devenus des
amis
ouais et vallées plein on fait de la
musique oui c'est vrai ça a tout
déclenché moi c'est à cause de ce
concert que j'ai décroché la guitare nos
papas alors jean louis aubert vous êtes
né en 1955 à nantua dans l'ain et votre
père était sous préfet mais bien sous
préfet aux champs caval'art effet folklo
pas tellement de pouvoir ils croyaient
pas à son business
non non il m'a bien montrer l'envers du
décor il se méfiait des politiques mais
c'est vrai je veux dire qu'elle avait
passé cinq ans en captivité que celle
l'avait un peu guéri peut-être des
idéologies pas ils me disent mais c'est
pas pareil sa rage
il ya un nouveau jour ce soir pour dire
mais il m'a toujours dit ce en captivité
que j'étais le plus libre parce que
chacun prenait sa place pour aider les
autres naturellement ce qui vous savez
trafic et boîtes de cancer pour faire
des rêves chose et ça et lui c'est là
qu'il a fait de la musique et comme il
connaissait beaucoup de deux poèmes
parker y réciter sa ses copains il
s'occuper un peu de leur esprit
alors effectivement il dessine et il
jouait de la guitare il accrocher la
guitare dans votre chambre
est ce que c'est un signe à votre avis
je sais pas en tout cas je les sages qui
vous passent et je pense mais surtout je
sais quand j'ai décroché à guise la
première fois que j'ai fait d
les premières notes il a fait d'autres
cieux que quand j'avais des bonnes notes
à l'école
bah oui le père de jean louis aubert
était en fait un artiste refoulé et qui
était passionné de greg d'étymologie et
qui vous a donné l'amour des mots
sûrement mais je me ratais apercevez pas
à l'école
voilà donc fils de sous préfet vous
déménagez beaucouzé de nantua à senlis
une enfance plutôt plutôt dorée des
grandes maisons des chauffeurs ddd bonne
desjardins d'ibn même des bonnes
annonces et s'appelait mignonne et lui a
montré son cul voilà il en avait aussi
accroché dans sa chambre alors une
enfance assez classique finalement vous
étiez vous étiez scouts enfants de
choeur enfin les voilà on y mange pas
demain pas tant une enfance assez
heureuse et que vos deux soeurs et en
fait vous ne réaliserez que bien plus
tard à quel point vous aviez souffert la
maison tente de vos parents ça sera dur
et comment non non c'est à dire quand on
est arrivé à paris on s'est retrouvé
dans un appartement à ces petits lits
dont coexistence et là j'ai découvert un
peu la vie avec mes parents et mes
parents ils ont aussi peut-être
découvert la vie promiscuité et là il ya
68 alors en 68 vous avait 13 ans et là
c'est la révolte qui commence c'est à
dire voilà le rockeur nez de gaulle qui
symbolise la l'autorité parentale vinci
est bien là vous commencez à discuter
avec les trotskistes avec les maoïstes
et anarchistes et tout ça et
situationniste et tout ça vous oblige à
lire marx bakounine pour voir des
arguments pour voir discuter
ouais enfin moi je survolais
alors c'est à la fois l'époque vous
achetez votre premier disque des beatles
et la fois à l'époque où vos parents
vous emmène de force au défi les
gaullistes des champs elysées le 30 juin
68 et ça ça vous a guéri de la politique
ce défilé obligatoire vous avez plus
jamais voter après non non ce qui m'a
d'abord je sais pas si je suis guéri de
la politique je m'intéresse au monde
mais aussi le c'est mon père quand
j'étais petit disait quand il parlait
des députés en particulier ils ont ils
trouvaient ça va faire mais ça magouille
est beaucoup à cette époque la lauréate
noms sont tous clean et donc non mais
vous vous croyez pas trop à la politique
vous dites je n'oublie pas que hitler a
été élu au suffrage universel c'est la
pure vérité et et vous dites si le front
national passé grâce à des élections
démocratiques
je n'accepterai pas les résultats je ne
suis pas démocrate à ce point c'est à
dire qu'effectivement vous avez une
méfiance de la politique je trouve que
quand on est je devrais peut-être pas
dire ça ça m'est arrivé de voter là j'ai
essayé pour voir c'était bizarre
normalement quand on vote on est censé
accepter le résultat des urnes ouais
c'est ça peut être embêtant
enfin c'est un peu une sorte de
séquences et quand il me semble qu
entendez des chansons envie d'en parler
ici on peut voter aussi finement soeur
parce que c'est un peu on peut dire des
choses ni noirs ni blancs sous large
mais si un président de république
d'extrême droite est élu au suffrage
universel vous ne reconnut criez pas le
verdict des urnes alors et vous noël moi
je me dirais que c'est les français ont
mérité ce qu'ils auront voté mais je
serai un peu comme jean louis oui je
vous serais plutôt prêts à prendre le
maquis qu'autre chose je me battrai
sinon c'est le je n'accepterai pas
effectivement que un pays se livrent aux
mains d'un facho c'est ce que vient de
faire l'italie et les cuire jusqu'au 10
ces pays et l'italie philippe moi c'est
pareil c'est pareil je suis pas j'ai
jamais bien compris ni admis la phrase
de voltaire qui dirait je suis si je
suis pas d'accord avec vous vous idée je
mourrai pour que vous puissiez les
exprimer
non c'est plutôt du côté de st juste pas
de liberté pour les ennemis de la
liberté
par exemple c'est là aurait bien aimé
avoir une situation une citation ne
l'est pas c'est vrai que dans des
témoignages de latifa on se dit qu'il ya
pas de liberté pour les ennemis des
liberty c'est à peu près ce qu'on peut
en déduire oui alors en 69 vous avez 14
ans et là effectivement oui les ou sur
scène donc là théâtre des champs-élysées
grand moment et après le concert vous
prenez la guitare et dj plus jamais
lâcher quoi ça a été pour vous là le
chemin de damas quoi ouais ouais c'était
vrai c'était très important surtout que
en allant à ce concert il y avait une
pièce d'art à bâle où les filles elles
avaient les femmes nues sur la photo
donc avec mon copain on avait 14 ans on
y est allé et et on a été reçus par des
gens très cultivés qui était très
content de voir des mômes rentrer mon a
pas dit que c'était pour les sens mais
il ya eu un vent de liberté un peu
culturel qui a soufflé sur nous ça plus
le concert des cultures
en fait notre premier groupe à 15 ans le
premier groupe s'appelle masturbation
vous même le savoir et tout est mis avec
olive de gérer les olives de lily dans
assyriens et puis antoine de caunes de
conakry vient principalement s'il ya une
belle batteries après vous avez au lycée
pasteur à neuilly vous allez jugnot
comme pion ouais mais c'est vers l'avant
ah oui t'es pas rigolo c'est pas rigolo
il y avait tous les deux l'équipe du
splendid donc c'était assez marrant de
voir midi avec xavier
certains aient été pion mais il aimait
ça qu'on fasse y est allé du bac bon
c'est vrai c'est pas parce que l'arrêté
pas terrible et deux moyennes vous êtes
viré de pasteur vous retrouvez à
retrouver et un quart no vous rencontrer
louis bertignac donc voilà les choses
commençaient un petit peu s'établir là
on commence à voir un peu là la génèse
de la faire ensuite je les la fac de
vincennes
c'était énorme la fac de vincennes
c'était tout sauf une fac quoi c'est
vrai moi j'ai passé un très bon c'était
bon alors vous faites de la musicologie
puis vous avez peur du tout là si je
continue je vais finir prof de musique
c'est ça hein mais c'était très très
instructif parce que j'ai vu plein de
choses que je voulais pas faire ouais
j'ai vu ce que je voulais pas faire
c'est d'essayer d'apprendre sur le tas
le groupe meetic de donc voyage aux usa
à ce moment-là voyage initiatique aux
usa qui vous a quelque part guéri de
l'american dream alors que vous faites à
la fois la manche vont jouer comme ça
pour les usa c'est l'atlantique
c'était avant l'angleterre est à la fois
voyez un concert de jefferson airplane
sommes tous à vous remplit évidemment de
bonheur mais malgré tout vous revenez un
peu gris du rêve américain savait pas
pourquoi il ya eu plusieurs bascule
mais à ce concert de jefferson starship
à l'époque oui le guitariste avait des
cheveux des baskets en drapeau américain
et samaa il sert et mares estimé non
retour vous rencontrer richard kolinka
donc et vous former ses molina
évidemment à cause de la chanson des
beatles and the walrus où il ya ces
molina pile car jacking von deck dogues
ice voilà vous faites des booms jouer en
smoking j'avoue qu'on fait des rallyes
dans le 16e et obligés de s'habiller en
smoking
non à billes être plus on est habillé
zazou et puisque vous laisser rentrer
dans les rallyes du cese à billets voilà
sans se moquer mais j'ai vu des trucs
très des cadres dans du sel
oui monsieur avoue fait une retraite
dans une grotte à ibiza oui on a tous
fait un rassurez vous je vous mangez du
lait et du miel uniquement du lait et du
miel non continue à faire la manche pour
sujet les dents des rennais vie sain
avait draps c'était la chanson blau
vedra et là vous composer mais trop
c'est trop
et après tout s'organise on a écouté ce
que ça a donné
[Musique]
alors on vous faire une interview
première fois vous êtes prêts on ne
bouge pas pendant le signal
oui
qu'est ce que c'est que ça j'ai oublié
qu'il avait bougé enfin qu'il fallait je
sais pas je sais plus il n'a fait que
bouger je regardais les autres serge
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a bougé ou pas
qu'est ce que tu en penses
comme dit l'interview voilà comme dit
l'interview alors premier souvenir
comment mêmes parents ma mère m'a
enfermé dans un placard elle m'a oublié
[Rires]
viennent mais elle ne s'en souvient pas
première prise juste avant j'imagine
j'en connais une autre à l'âge de trois
ans le suisse 35 terrible avant j'avais
tiré l'alarmé il y avait une arme à la
maison ça c est l art du chauffeur de
votre alarme du chauffeur de mon père
j'ai pris un petit 6 35 chargé et je
suis arrivé il y avait des invités et
j'ai fait aux les mains et tout le monde
a levé les mains
et
première aventure avec un garçon ça je
vous aventurer aventure touche pipi quoi
il ya peu il ya eu une période où
j'étais tout le temps de mettre tout nu
avec des petits garçons je sais pas si
vous avez fait ça enfin voulait bien sûr
mais moi aussi j'ai fait ça et là et
donc vers un métier terrain et c'était
bah oui c'était ce qui m'étonne c'est
que ça se passait très très rapidement
grèce à 13,13 vatican quoi premier
baiser
on va en provence
et j'étais un peu petit et essayer de
monter sur un tronc d'arbre
mais ça avait pris des heures précises
heure pour moi c'est la glace et ça fait
très vieux après pour ça recommence isr
surtout les jeunes je fais mieux un jeu
moyen ça va beaucoup plus vite
première expérience sexuelle en
l'attention j'ai aussi la réponse je
vois tout à fait où c'était avec qui 16
ans ouais c'est ça chez un copain
pendant l'été mais jean-marc ça
s'appelait comment véronique borvo c'est
là qu'il a ressorti son 6,35 cahier des
charges est couvert par tous
c'est parce que c'est bon j'ai jamais eu
ça mais bon alors une partie carrée ah
oui bon petit verre de 18 ans 19 ans et
vous me direz vous avez des partis car
est aussi oui je gêne pas pour courir
contre l'abattage et les parties car
elle vaut de quoi aider coup ils sont
chassés
quand même d'accord très bon disque ça
va la pharma vous fait vous êtes en
forme physiquement musicalement ça se
passe bien ouais c'est mon fils panne
loin bien mesdames messieurs nous allons
passer au blind test alors attention ce
soir c'est un spécial il chante en
famille donc les frères les soeurs les
fils les filles etc
mais évidemment pour arbitrer le blind
test j'accueille un homme au dessus de
tout soupçon
masure a fait partie
[Applaudissements]
si si
[Musique]
c'est une oeuvre la pipe ouais tout va
bien didier faivre est en passe de blind
test
[Applaudissements]
bien attention tout le monde est bien
concentré noël et il n'y a pas le nom du
gagnant sur la non alors vous connaissez
le principe à un philippe geluck je veux
le nom des chanteurs également du wifi
je vois
[Applaudissements]
d'abord d'abord ses lombaires il a
trouvé ça génial
[Applaudissements]
quelle valeur du site italien qui a
soufflé talea qu'est ce qu'on a dit bien
soufflage et propage un coup chacun
tirait à bon compte immunité
avec moi ici et je dois dire philippe
geluck et orlando mais orlando qu'est-ce
qui se passe les beach boys quand même
je vais enfin la fidh
bah oui titov it be oui je savais je
savais je savais les spas non j'avais je
reste inchangé jusqu'au fond du car et
en version double trône et ses
attentions didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou non
[Musique]
avec la version effectivement c'était
des frères et des soeurs de petits
malgaches qui s'appelait les soeurs
évidemment or j'ai pas dis évidemment
les jackson five et et des frères des
beach boys avaient des parts les soeurs
je ne vivais que pour nous non pas 15
ans et les 50 on bénit la chasse en
chantier
[Musique]
oasis tout le monde sait que ce sont des
frères oasis bravo jean louis aubert
tant que je signale simplement qu'ils
sont à 3 de ce côté là et vous êtes cas
j'espère
[Applaudissements]
orlando bien trouver l'argent doit
trouver des surfs et cette année
attention pillés
[Musique]
le foyer gilani gainsbourg et puis comme
noël mamère s'est laissé souffler dans
l'oreille c'est vrai oui
c'est ça
rabaisser la clé c'est ch pendant ces
sacrifices déjà mais également c'est la
septième fois colis de plus souffler
didier bah oui
[Musique]
prêts
sifflé
[Applaudissements]
19 il est blessé ça dit non on continue
[Musique]
rien n'est moins garçon sérieux l'un est
bien en continu attention à prendre
mais vous voyez dans un cas pareil moi
j'ai fait ouais parce que j'étais
heureux qu'on ait trouvé bon c'est eux
mais j'étais heureux comme moi ce que je
veux c'est que j'ai mes fans soufflage j
ai pas de soufflage l'équipe de noël
mamère il avait été scié ce que loin
devant parce que aurait réflexion
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est très très dur
[Musique]
autre ombre non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cannes et dans le respect absolu parce
que cela il a mis l'histoire ont cédé en
finale alors c'est à dire qu'à souffler
ya je ne sais pas et je ne sais pas
vraiment ça tu aimes ça souffle et un
[Applaudissements]
lobby donne une double à orlando situe à
souffler et on ne peut que saluer le
personnel de l'hôtel martinez
évidemment qui nous accueille tout l'été
en tout cas cela il family stone c'est
très dur woodstock jeu prévient qu'il
[Applaudissements]
est chez nous continuer je fais vaincu
la salle
[Applaudissements]
montant n'est pas
de l'ordre
m
c'est moi galaxy bon attention
didier
[Musique]
un choix pas
nicolas oui
[Applaudissements]
nat king cole le père et fille là c'est
simplement un petit peu de culture
musicale
alors que le père était déjà mort alors
que le père était déjà on avait à
l'oreille musicale
j'entends moi aussi à monsieur non
mesurés témoin de la corruption qui
règne sur les plateaux de télévision
ma mère quand vous serez président je
supprime les plateaux de télévision
d'accord sur l'idée
[Musique]
ce faire là
c
[Applaudissements]
sabra comment jab et c'est bien
progresser sinatra le père et la fille
maintenant il ya le super bowl attention
attention vous savez dans le super banco
tout peut changer en juillet c'est
injuste mais la vie est injuste oui
allez ici pour support est à lire dans
nos obligé dahlias on est obligé c'est
une mesure de salut public menu mesures
de sécurité super lent quotas via
bayonne et voilà attention didier et
j'ai vu ce genre mon pote
j'ai fait mes classes au japon
demande de vous arrêter
thierry ouais tu as raison des règles
que nous avons instaurée dans ce plan
une thèse qui sont strictes et ils m'ont
vite mis publiques cotées sous verre
soufflé jeudi kardon
et cissé
[Applaudissements]
c'est cet indien
je veux
[Applaudissements]
c'était tout le monde l'émission
vraiment pas comme les autres avec leurs
papilles sexe magouille et culture
générale jeu laurent lundi avec laurent
baffie pascal celma demain gagné le rue
joe géraldine bonnet verra et c'est au
gymnase charlotte gainsbourg
ma femme est une actrice de yvan attal
avec charlotte gainsbourg
à table sortie le 14 novembre et
monsieur london
aujourd'hui les astres c'est chez plon
c'est la thèse de et il avait apprécié
qu'elle n'assure plus la sorbonne et qui
vient permis de devenir docteur en
sociologie
voilà et puis aussi chez philippe a
quitté les jours votre horoscope 2002
il parle elisabeth tessier mesdames
messieurs orlando hollande-aubry david a
la vida
mission numéro 5 le single s'appelle lui
c'est moi dans ces essais remixé par ses
robes
c'est moi danser la ligue 1 remixé par
ses robes
merci orlando d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir
titoff titoff
jean
[Applaudissements]
novembre alors on le 14 mai
les bains le 15 novembre à strasbourg
shipping le siège à youth et le 29 30 et
31 décembre à l'olympia salle jean marie
messier plus le dvd du spectacle depuis
sort le 20 novembre la verchère
le titre voilà fédéraux troupe sitl dans
le film de gilles paquet brenner et qui
s'appelle
joli show avec marion cotillard
patricola accéder reiss était à celui
belgique et aux pays-bas heures et ça
aussi ça sort le 14 novembre
[Applaudissements]
la mesure
le onzième album mais charles
si pour les amateurs le fils du chah tu
sors le 24 décembre chez casterman
comme au petit nombre en voilà noël
mamère candidats l'hiver la présidence
carter noël valeurs vedettes
et la tipa latifa visage volée
pointant qu'à bouge chez anne carrière
voilà je gagne me reste à vous dire que
jean louis aubert à sortir un album qui
s'appelle l'album comme un accord
l'album de jean charles
comme un accord le single s'appelle
alter ego merci jean louis et philippe
corti diva
[Applaudissements]
c'était tout nouveau bar on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine merci d'être aussi
fidèle et aussi nombreux à ce rendez
vous merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
non
[Musique]
m
rien
[Musique]
m
je suis
[Musique]
je vois
non
[Musique]
et